Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 11 mit Frank und Fefe. Dieses Mal geht es überraschenderweise um Ägypten. Eigentlich hatten wir ja versprochen, dass wir eine Folge mit dem Daniel Domscheit-Berg zu OpenLeaks machen, haben dann aber bei der Vorbereitung der Sendung festgestellt, dass es bei OpenLeaks dann noch so einige Fragen gibt, die noch der Bearbeitung, Beantwortung harren. Und da wir euch natürlich nicht mit einer Sendung abspeisen wollten, wo es dann ganz oft heißt, da müssen wir noch gucken, und das müssen wir noch erarbeiten, und das mache ich ganz klar, dachten wir uns, verschieben wir diese Sendung mal, bis diese Fragen beantwortbar sind. Also es ist auf jeden Fall nur verschoben, nicht aufgehoben. Holen wir nach, sobald es da eben genau diese Antworten gibt und wir dann halt eine Sendung machen können, wo alle Fragen, die ihr so habt und die ihr uns über Twitter reichlich geschickt habt, beantwortet werden können.
Hat uns jetzt natürlich hart getroffen, dass die Seite online gegangen ist nach dem Kryptom-Leak.
Ja, sie sind ja ein Leak-Opfer geworden. Aber eigentlich wollen wir auch dann nicht unbedingt irgendwie exklusiv sein oder die ersten oder so. sondern es geht halt uns ja primär darum, eben die Hintergrundfragen zum Antworten haustechnischer Sicht, die andere Leute nicht so in ihrer Sendung bringen können. Weil vielleicht...
Na ja, wir wollen schon die ersten sein. Wir wollen aber auch die besten sein.
Genau. Gut, da sind wir jetzt nicht mal die ersten, aber wir sind die besten. Sind ja die ersten besten.
Von daher sind wir nicht die erst besten.
Ja, noch mal Entschuldigung für die lange sendepause. Es war halt irgendwie ein harter Kongress, und dann waren wir beide so ein bisschen krank und unsere zarten Stimmchen waren etwas in mittleidenschaft gezogen. Deswegen konnten wir dann auch nicht so richtig, und dann kam noch dieses Problem mit Openix dazu. jedenfalls hier sind wir wieder die Folge 11. Wir sagen nochmal Danke fürs zahlreiche Flattern trotz der sendepause. Wir hoffen doch, dass wir in der nächsten Folge noch ein paar Sachen dazu sagen können, was wir mit dem Flattergeld anfangen. Was wir versprochen hatten, war, dass wir davon interessante Bücher und interessante Subskriptionen von irgendwelchen OBSCORE-Online-Diensten kaufen.
Die Ägyptenreise mussten wir erstmal absagen.
Die Ägyptenreise mussten wir leider erstmal absagen. Das wäre irgendwie Alternativlos live aus Kairo wäre auch mal was gewesen. Ja, Kairo, da wären wir schon beim Thema. Wie ihr gerade alle sicherlich live im Fernsehen verfolgt oder verfolgen konntet oder primär auch im Internet und im Twitter verfolgen könnt, ist in Ägypten gerade sowas ähnliches wie Revolutionen. zumindest steht offensichtlich eine änderung der momentanen Herrscherungsverhältnisse an. Die bisherige Regierung ist ja doch schon eher etwas länger im Amt und hat sich nicht direkt dadurch ausgezeichnet, dass sie noch über nachhaltige Rückhalte im Fall verfügt.
Kannst du dich noch an eine Zeit vor, wo Barack erinnern?
Nein, der regiert doch schon seit was? 30 Jahren?
Ja, das ist mir gerade bei der Vorbereitung so ein bisschen aufgefallen. Ich hab auch echt Schwierigkeiten gehabt, einen seiner Vorgänger zu nennen.
Also wir haben jetzt mal durchgeklickt.
Also wenn man sich ein bisschen damit wieder eindeckt und so, dann fallen die einem schon ein.
Ich kann mich erinnern, aus den Erzählungen meines Vaters über die damaligen Krisen, da kamen halt immer noch so andere Regierungsnamen vor.
Ja, Sadat kam mal vor. Aber Nasser kenne ich eigentlich nur aus Agentenfilmen.
Ja gut, wir fangen mal ein bisschen an mit einem kleinen Rückblick auf, wie ist denn dieses Ägypten an seiner heutigen Konstellation zusammengefunden, weil durch was für Krisen es da so ging, da hat FIFA sich da so ein wenig vorbereitet.
Ja, also eigentlich war ja die Hauptfrage für mich, wieso interessiert uns eigentlich Ägypten, wenn uns Tunesien nicht interessiert hat. Was ist denn jetzt an Ägypten so besonderes? Und Ägypten ist eigentlich ein Hebel für den ganzen Kontinent Afrika. Also die heute existierende Republik Ägypten ist 1952 gegründet worden, Ergebnis von Militärputsch. Vorher war da eine Monarchie. Und Ägypten hat 1948 noch einen Krieg mitgemacht, der ein Krieg praktisch der arabischen Welt gegen das neu gegründete Land Israel damals. Und da sind sie geschlagen worden. Ägypten hatte in dem Krieg die größte Armee von allen arabischen ländern.
Und sie hatten deutsche Söldner.
Und sie hatten deutsche Söldner, ja. Sehr peinlich. Peinliches Kapitel in der deutschen Geschichte.
Direkt nach dem deutschen Krieg, nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, sind da offensichtlich etliche Wehrmacht und SS-Offiziere hingegangen und haben geholfen, die ägyptische Armee aufzustellen, auszubilden, um sie gegen Israel in den Krieg zu führen.
Die haben sich halt gedacht, was mache ich mit dem, was ich kann?
Dunkles Kapitel. Daraus resultierte dann interessanterweise am ende, nach einigen hin und her, ein Gesetz, wonach es Deutschen verboten ist, sich in ausländischen Militärdiensten zu verdingen, außer bei der französischen fremden Legion.
Weil das sind ja unsere freunde.
Ja, weil das sind ja unsere freunde, genau.
Also ich finde es spannend an der Stelle, dass mir das überhaupt nichts gesagt hat. Von diesem Skandal habe ich noch nie irgendwas gehört. Aber Frank wusste das und meine Theorie dazu ist, dass die DDR ja durchaus bemüht war, die Fehlleistungen der bundesrepublik aufklärerisch dem eigenen Volk zu vermitteln.
Also ich konnte mich jetzt nicht so richtig erinnern, wann ich zum ersten Mal von dieser Geschichte gehört habe. Das ist ja eine größere Sache. Da gibt es auch einen sehr ausführlichen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu. Zum deutschen Engagement von deutschen Wissenschaftlern und Ingenieuren in Ägypten, die damals in den 50er Jahren eine Rüstungsindustrie aufgebaut haben. Die haben sogar ein eigenes Flugzeug entwickelt.
Und Raketen. Also auch die Leute, die am deutschen Raketenprogramm mitgearbeitet haben, die nicht von den Amis oder Russen abgegriffen wurden.
Genau, die dritte Garnitur sozusagen. Die sind dann halt in Ägypten gelandet und haben versucht, dann da in Kurzstrecken ein Raketenprogramm. Also muss man überlegen, in den 50er-Jahren, also das, worüber wir heute immer noch reden, halt die Bedrohung Israels durch Raketen, war damals halt schon eine akute Angelegenheit. So und die hat sich dann im Wesentlichen von selber erledigt, zum einen halt durch, sicherlich durch Interventionen, da der Großmächte bei der bundesrepublik, aber die meinten dann auch, sie könnten noch nicht so viel tun, aber dann ist den Ägyptern dann halt auch irgendwann die krude ausgegangen und sie haben sich in ihrem Spiel, sich mit den Russen bzw. den Sowjets zu verbünden oder den Amis, dann halt irgendwann entschieden. Dadurch ist dieses ganze Bedrohungspotenzial, was es da gab, nie so richtig zum Tragen gekommen. Es gab damals auch noch irgendwelche Geschichten, dass die Ägypter auch ein eigenes Atomprogramm anfahren wollten, aber dafür fehlten ihnen die Ressourcen.
Das spannende ist jedenfalls, diesen Wikipedia-Artikel, den werden wir auch verlinken, den kann man also nur empfehlen. Der liest sich sehr spannend, weil in der deutschen Wikipedia, weil so praktisch jeder zweite Satz zu relativieren versucht, entweder wie viel die Deutschen da gemacht haben, oder dass es nur ganz wenige waren, oder dass das Programm ja eigentlich sowieso zum Scheitern verurteilt war. Und so, also wenn ich mir so was lese, das ist mir echt aufgefallen an dem Artikel, dann frage ich mich, war das jetzt wirklich so, oder ist das halt, weil es in der deutschen Wikipedie steht?
Das ist rechtfertig, oder wie?
Ja, man weiß es nicht.
Aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, den Artikel zu lesen und die reichlich vorhandenen Literaturhinweise. Wahrscheinlich habe ich diesen Artikel jetzt wegen Irrelevanz zur Lösung verdammt. Da habe ich das so in Erwähnt an.
Mensch, Frank.
Ja, diese Wissensverdichtung.
Furchtbar.
Na gut, der nächste größere Krieg war dann die Suess-Krise. Da gab es dann halt schon diesen Militärputsch, 1952, von so einigen Offizieren. Das war so einer der ersten. Nee, das war der zweite Militärputsch, ne?
Also das war der erste, den ich gefunden habe.
Der erste, den ich gefunden habe. 1952.
Also seitdem regiert auch das Militär eigentlich so.
Und es gibt, ist ganz wichtig für das Verständnis der Ereignisse der nächsten Wochen, es gibt durchaus eine Historie von erfolgreichen Militärputschern, jüngeren Offizieren. Also es ist so, dass die im Geschichtsbewusstsein der Ägypter es verankert, dass ein Militärputsch der jüngeren Offiziere gegen das existierende Regime durchaus Erfolg haben kann.
Und nicht unbedingt was schlechtes ist.
Und nicht unbedingt was schlechtes ist, oder?
Also der erste, die erste Regierung hat einen, noch einen General übernommen, aber der war eigentlich gar nicht der, der die Revolution angezettelt hatte, sondern das war nur ein Oberst, nämlich der Oberst Gamal abdel Nasser, der ist dann der nächste regierende geworden. Und dessen erstes Projekt war natürlich nach dem furchtbaren Ausgang des ersten Krieges gegen Israel noch mal ein Krieg gegen Israel, um das auszuwetzen, weil eben das, der Ägypten hat halt den größten Teil der arabischen Militärmacht gestellt im ersten Krieg gegen Israel und der war nicht gut gelaufen. Und das nagt am Selbstbewusstsein des Militärs und der Bevölkerung. Ansonsten war der Nasser allerdings ein Sozialist und hat auch sich bemüht, nahe Beziehungen mit der Sowjetunion zu pflegen und hat sich damit natürlich bei den Amis unbeliebt gemacht. Das war so eine Zeit, wo noch nicht klar war, wer jetzt eigentlich die neueste große Supermacht werden wird. Und die Afrikaner haben eigentlich alle, die länder, die schlauenden Afrikaner, haben die versucht, gegeneinander auszuspielen und haben halt versucht, so jeweils Konzessionen von dem anderen zu kriegen, damit, dass sie halt offen gedroht haben, dann eben mit dem anderen jeweils irgendwelche Sachen zu machen.
Und so eine der wichtigsten Aktionen, die der Nasser gemacht hat, war halt, den Suos-Kanal zu verstaatlichen, der halt zu dem Zeitpunkt noch in so einer privaten Firma organisiert war.
Und mit Einfluss der Briten.
Mit Einfluss der Briten, die ja da die traditionelle Kolonialmacht waren. Und das hat die Briten und die Franzosen echt angeüdet.
Die waren wirklich sauer, so sauer, dass sie eine Militäraktion gemacht haben.
Genau, zusammen mit den Israelis 1956. Haben die Israelis mit Unterstützung von Frankreich und Großbritannien auf den Suuskanal vorgestoßen über die Sinai-Halbinsel. Und mit dem Versuch, ihnen halt, also damals dieses unter internationale Kontrolle zu bringen, aber warum es halt tatsächlich ging, war halt ganz klar. Also israelische und englische Kontrolle.
Aber Israel auch mit der Proxy gewesen wäre, oder meinst du?
Israel war der Proxy, ja. Da gab es dann so einen Gerangel, so dass es halt, also die Franzosen und Briten sind dann zum ägyptischen Botschafter in London gegangen, haben ihm einen Waffenstillstandsvertrag unter die Nase gehalten. Mit 12 stunden Frist, in dem sowas stand, wie die Israelis rücken bis auf eine 10 Kilometer Pufferzone an den Kanal vor. Soweit waren die Israelis zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht vorgestoßen. Und dann diese 10 Kilometer Zone um den Kanal wurde dann internationales Territorium. Blabla, ja. Also Protektorat und so. Und dann zahlte sich aber aus, dass der Nasser zu dem Zeitpunkt halt mit den Sowjets gekuschelt hatte. Was dann nämlich passierte, war, trotzdem gerade, das ist so, obwohl, ne, vielleicht nicht obwohl, sondern weil gerade zu der selben Zeit der Auftrag in Ungarn war, da ist also die Sowjets die hände alle voll hatten. Also das war nicht so, dass ich...
Und die sagt dir, nimm was du brauchst.
Ne, ne, was dann passierte, ist, dass da gab es dann so ein denkwürdiges Gespräch, das war so ein Interview, was glaube ich, des sowjetischen Premierministers damals, der irgendwie so was sagte, naja, also wenn die Briten und die Franzosen da so gegen die Ägypter vorgehen, so, dann würden auch die Sowjetinnen und sich genötigt sind, britische und französische Städter als legitime Ziele für sowjetische Nuklearwaffen anzusehen. Den Themenblick mussten die dann wohl mal ganz dringend auf die Bremse treten und wirklich versuchen, da noch irgendwie eine Lösung zu finden, die irgendwie nicht, ja, also die sozusagen unterhalb der Nuklear-Schwelle. Obwohl man 1956 zu dem Zeitpunkt hatte, diese Wörter waren auch nicht so richtig doll viele Atomwaffen, aber es war halt irgendwie...
Man hat mit einem gedroht, was sie hatten, so.
Es war halt nur, also ich meine Hiroshima war irgendwie gerade mal ein bisschen mehr als zehn Jahre her. Das heißt, man konnte sich da noch echt frisch dran erinnern. Und dann hatten die Amis auch keinen Bock. Also die USA haben dann halt den Franzosen und den Englern dann ihre Unterstützung verweigert, weil sie keine Lust hatten, sich wegen so einer Kleinigkeit damit, der Sowjetinnen, halt in einen offenen Schlagabstausch zu begeben, weil darauf ist sie hinausgelaufen.
Naja, Kleinigkeit. Also wir sollten noch ein bisschen begründen, warum der SUS-Kanal eigentlich so wichtig ist.
Also durch den SUS-Kanal laufen aktuell etwa so zehn Prozent des welthandels auf Schiffen. Das heißt also, der momentan fahren so was zwischen 40 und 50 Schiffe durch den SUS-Kanal pro Tag, also große Containerschiffe. Der SUS-Kanal ist halt groß, da passt echt was durch. Und also der ist so groß, dass man da auch einen aktuellen Flugzeugträger durchfahren kann, also nochmal so die Dimension klarzumachen. Also wenn auch knapp, aber es geht. Und der SUS-Kanal hat so ein Statut, unter dem er betrieben wird. Und das irgendwie von kurz nach der Erbauung stammte, so 1880 oder so was. Und da steht unter anderem drin, dass er also eine offene internationale Wasserstraße ist, wo man natürlich Gebühren für die Durchwärter richten muss, aber auch Kriegsschiffe, Krieg für eine Staaten dürfen da jederzeit passieren, ohne eigentlich ohne anzuhalten. Sie dürfen halt nicht irgendwie unterwegs dann noch mal bremsen und sich mit Wasser versorgen oder so.
Aber das ist schon relativ einzigartig. Normalerweise nimmt man sich natürlich als Betreiberland die Option raus, Schiffen die Durchfahrt zu verweigern. Und das geht halt hier nicht außer sie zahlen nicht.
Außer sie zahlen nicht, genau. Und das ist halt so, dass die, wenn man sich also anguckt, die Alternative zum durch den Sooskanal fahren, ist halt einmal komplett um Afrika rumschippern.
Das Horn von Afrika. Also Wikipedia hat eine Statistik dazu und hat gesagt, der Seeweg zwischen dem Hauptöl-Exporthafen der Saudis und Rotterdam, wo Europa die gesamten Importe abwickelt, der wird 44 Prozent länger, wenn er den Sooskanal umgehen muss. Also das ist schon deutlich. Und das kostet eben deutlich mehr. Übrigens auch eine Durchfahrt durch den Sooskanal. Der Preis bestimmt sich so nach der Tonnage. Und so ein Tanker zahlt da schon mal 100.000 bis eine Million. Also das ist schon auch nicht ganz billig. Aber wenn man bedenkt, was die da für eine Zeitersparnis haben und das kostet ja auch Treibstoff, einfach um Afrika rumzudümpeln, dann lohnt sich das schon. Ja, die werden das schon kalkuliert haben, ganz klar.
Also das geht dann sicherlich nicht nach rein Unterhaltskosten, sondern nach irgendwie, was würde es sonst kosten. Und dementsprechend hoch ist halt der SUS-Kanal halt auch in Ägypten priorisiert.
Der ist richtig deutsch-scheiße wertvoll.
Und das heißt also, die Struktur der Betreiberorganisation des SUS-Kanals innerhalb von Ägypten ist halt auch nahezu autark. Also die haben da eigene Transportunternehmen, eigene Kliniken, eigene Stromversorgung, die haben eine eigene militärische Schutztruppe, die sich halt darum kümmert, dass da irgendwie niemand an den Kanal kommt. Die haben einen Tunnel unter dem SUS-Kanal, damit sich schnell Militär von eines auf die andere verlegen kann, weil Brücken gibt es halt nicht.
Es gibt auch Brücken, die sind ganz witzig. Eine, die ich besonders witzig fand, ist die friedensbrücke, die mubarak-friedensbrücke. Da hat sie ausgerechnet im Jahre 2001 oder so ist die relativ frisch. Also es gibt schon Brücken, es gibt auch ältere Brücken, die sind dann aber keine festen Brücken, sondern die werden so draufgeschwenkt. Ja, aber im Wesentlichen gibt es halt Regeln, wie hoch so ein Boot sein darf, damit es sehr lang schippert. Und das ist schon verdammt scheiße hoch. Das heißt, diese friedensbrücke von Mubarak, das ist eine Hängebrücke, aber die ist halt richtig doll hoch. Die sieht auch schon so aus, als wenn da wirklich dicke Schiffe unten durchpassen würden.
Verstehe.
Aber noch mal so ein bisschen zu...
Unter neuerer Zeit ist es ganz wichtig zu wissen, dass der SUS-Kanal eben die kürzeste Verbindung zwischen dem Mittelmeer und dem Roten Meer ist. Eine der Dinge, die man gerne ins Meer schmeißt oder übers Meer zieht, sind Kabel. Das heißt also Glasfaserkabel. Dementsprechend, da kommen wir später noch mal im Detail drauf, geht halt auch ein Großteil des Datenverkehrs zwischen Europa und Asien genau am SUS-Kanal lang. Das ist eine extrem wichtige geografische Stelle. Aber ihr wollt noch ein bisschen mehr zur Geschichte erzählen, oder?
Noch ein bisschen mehr zur Geschichte, genau. Um ein bisschen zu beleuchten, die Ägypter, die sind nicht nur ein sehr großes Land und haben auch echt viele Einwohner, sondern die sehen sich auch so ein bisschen als Vorherrschung. Irgendwie dreimal so hohe, große Fläche wie Deutschland, wenn ich recht bin zu nennen. Und die haben auch mal mit Syrien und dem Nordjemen zusammen ein Land gegründet. Das war mir völlig in Gang, hab ich heute gelernt.
Dieses pan-arabische Projekt?
Genau. Vereinigten Arabischen Republik hieß das damals. Und das hat nur drei Jahre gehalten, insofern war es nicht sonderlich erfolgreich. Aber da sieht man mal, dass die schon durchaus grandiose Ansprüche hätten. Also dieses Projekt, da gab es so eine ganz lustige Zitat zu, dass die Ägypter verstaatlichten alle in Syrien tätigen Firmen und Banken und bestimmten Kairo zur Hauptstadt. Die Regierung war fast komplett aus Ägyptern besetzt. Also da kann man sehen, dass Syrien dann nicht so toll hat, sich zurückgezogen und dann zerbrachte das. Aber ich meine, da sieht man den Anspruch, den Ägypten an sich selbst hat und als vorherrschende Macht in der Gegend. Also Ägypten ist wichtig wirtschaftlich gesehen. Ägypten hat auch eine sehr große Armee. Wir haben den ersten Krieg erwähnt. Also der Nasser hat halt dann nochmal einen Krieg geführt auf der Sinai-Halbinsel gegen Israel. Und das war der Sechs-Tage-Krieg, den hat Israel sofort.
Und den haben sie echt verkackt, ja.
Also richtig klar gewonnen, Israel hat klar gewonnen. Und die gesamte arabische Welt düpiert damit, ja. Und Nasser hat daraufhin seinen Rücktritt angeboten, blieb aber noch drei Jahre im Amt, bis er an Herzinfarkt, glaube ich, gestorben ist. Und der ist ein Volksheld gewesen damals. Es hieß irgendwie, bei seiner Beerdigung sind fünf Millionen Leute irgendwie mitmarschiert oder haben da irgendwie... Also das war richtig. nachdem es jetzt auch irgendwie einiges benannte, also der ist ein richtiger Volksheld, der Mann, obwohl er da verloren hat. Und nachdem Sechs-Tage-Krieg hat er noch mal ein bisschen weiter Krieg geführt gegen Israel. Das war der sogenannte Embüdungskrieg. Da ging es halt darum, die haben gesagt, na, wir haben viel mehr Einwohner als Israel. Das heißt, wenn wir einfach eine Weile gegen die Krieg führen, dann können die irgendwann nicht mehr und geben auf, was aber nicht stattgefunden hat natürlich. Aber die haben halt noch mal so auf auf kleinerer Flamme ein paar Jahre gegen Israel Krieg geführt. Und das brodelt schon seit vielen Jahren vor sich hin da in der Gegend, würde ich sagen. Und das Ägypten heute als ruhiger Pfahl, der die Gegend stabil hält, gilt, ist eine neuere Entwicklung. Also historisch gesehen ist das eigentlich eher Kriegstreiber gewesen und selbst Allmachtsansprüche. Und hat auch Krieg gegen das Osmanische Reich geführt. Also es geht schon länger zurück, die idee, dass das Ägypten da Mittel macht. Genau. Na gut. Dieser Ermüdungskrieg ist überhaupt auch nur möglich gewesen, weil die Sowjetunion großzügig mitgeholfen hat. Und das war eben dieser Proxy-Krieg. Also da hat die Sowjetunion auch keinen Bock drauf gehabt. Aber die afrikanischen länder haben damals halt gemerkt, dass sie echt einen Hebel in der Hand haben gegen beide. Also wenn die zur Sowjetunion gegangen sind und gesagt haben, ach wisst ihr, wir haben auch ein gutes Angebot von den Amis, dann haben die Sowjetzer halt geholfen. Weil irgendwie das ging gar nicht, dass man irgendwie das Gesicht verliert und dass da die länder abspringen, doch aus eigenem Willen und nicht aus irgendwelchen tatsächlichen Bedrohungen heraus. Das ging gar nicht. Und das haben die Ägypter schon durchaus genutzt. Und zum Höhepunkt von diesem Krieg hieß es, das waren sogar 1500 Militärberater der Russen damals in Ägypten stationiert, um denen zu helfen. Und es ging natürlich auch bei diesem Krieg um den Suezkanal.
Und danach, sein Nachfolger, hat der 73. Jom Kippurkrieg gegen Israel geführt.
Dann ging es auch um den Suezkanal.
Genau, und dann den Sinai. Und danach gab es dann halt sozusagen den Statusquoten. Dieser Jom Kippurkrieg ist insofern interessant, als dass es halt einer der letzten ziemlich modernen Kriege war, die halt in dieser Gegend so in großem Stil geführt wurden.
Auch mit breiten aktueller Technik für damalige Verhältnisse.
Also ein bisschen dazu, dass die... Ich glaube, da war es sogar so, dass die NVA hat da ein paar MIG-21 gespendet, die sie dahin geflogen zusammengeschraubt haben. Und die sie dann natürlich prompt an die Israelis verlor haben. Also jedenfalls irgendwie war halt nur so mäßig kompetent alles. Und dann gab es genau diese Geschichte mit der, dass die ägyptischen Truppen haben bei der Gelegenheit, den Suezkanal schnell überqueren müssen, weil sie auf der falschen Seite davon waren.
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach, wie man denkt, weil es halt wirklich ein breites Stück Gewässer ist da.
Ja, und dann haben sie diese neuen sowjetischen Pontonbrücken gehabt, mit denen sie da rüber kamen.
Und die Israelis haben auch schnell irgendwas improvisiert an der Stelle und sind auch zurück über den... Also das war schon eine sehr spannende Sache aus technischer Sicht damals dieser Krieg. Richtig gewonnen hat eigentlich keiner was. Also das ging so ein bisschen... Am Anfang sah es sehr gut aus für Ägypten, weil die Israelis nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass sie sich so schnell wieder rappeln. Und dann haben die Israelis aber angefangen zurückzuhauen und sind also auch schon wieder ihrerseits über den Suess-Kanal rübergekommen. Und da gab es dann Uno-Verhandlungen. Und da haben dann beide Seiten das quasi als ihren Sieg dargestellt. Und dann war ihnen politisch alles okay.
Ja und der Sieg hat immer noch so eine interessante, ja demilitarisierte Zone-Status. da gibt es offiziell keinen ägyptischen Truppen, sondern nur so Uno-Beobachter und ägyptische Polizei, die halt die Grenze nach Gaza da blockiert. Und der, also bin noch mal rumgefahren im Urlaub und da gibt es irgendwie so...
Ich frag jetzt nicht.
Naja, wenn man halt da so am Planschen ist, dann schaue ich...
Ich schaue auch immer beim Urlaub irgendwelche Militärstußpunkte abfahren.
Nein, nein, das war völlig überraschend. Wir waren irgendwie in der Chamei Sheik und sind dann... Also in der Nähe von Chamei Sheik und sind dann halt da hochgefahren zu diesem Kloster, St. Katharinenkloster, was halt so mitten in der Wüste ist. Das ist halt insofern lustig, das ist halt das Kloster, wo halt mit Moses und diesen ganzen Dingen und dann der brennende Dornbusch. Du erinnerst dich in den brennenden Dornbusch, Sabine. Und diesen Dornbusch gibts da in dem Kloster. Also aus einem Zweig von diesem Dornbusch gibts da halt so einen großen Dornbusch in der Woche da. Und da neben ihm hängt ein großes Schild, bitte nicht rauchen. Und da steht ein Feuerlösch. Nicht auch mal jemand einen brennenden Dornbusch verursacht. jedenfalls auf dem Weg dahin fährt man plötzlich, also da gibts so mehrere von so, naja, diese Typen, die man jetzt immer im Fernsehen sieht in Cairo, was ist das mit so etwas militärischem Haschen. Und dann diesen viereckigen Jacken, also diesen Jacken mit diesen viereckigen Taschen, das ist halt so die Security-Schläger, die da halt irgendwie dann so diverse Roadblocks haben, so gucken, dass man nur ein harmloser Tourist ist. Und dann so mitten in der Wüste irgendwo, gibts dann am Straßenrand einen amerikanischen Militärstützpunkt. Also anders kann ich es nicht beschreiben. Also offiziell ist es wahrscheinlich kein amerikanischer Militärstützpunkt, aber...
Ohne Blauhelme.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist halt so komplett US-Military-Issue, alles. So der Zaun, der Tor, das Wachhäuschen, die Schranke, irgendwie die Antennen sind irgendwie amerikanisch, das ist ein ägyptischer Stützpunkt, die die komplette Hardware von den Amis bekommen. Mit allen Beschriftungen und allem Drum und Dran, oder die Amis haben dann noch keine Ahnung, eine kleine Folterbase oder so, mitten in der Wüste.
Ja, kann natürlich sein. Rendition, da war Ägypten auch einer der ersten Leute, leiten länder, die ja mitgemacht haben.
Ja, na jedenfalls, der Siener ist halt offiziell demilitarisiert und da gibt es halt irgendwie diese, irgendwelche Security-Truppen, die halt die Palästinenser in Schach halten sollen. Und eben diese Unubeobachter, die, von denen es jetzt gestern hieß, dass sie die wohl evakuieren sollen oder so, weil sie nicht so richtig wussten.
Weil sie jetzt erstmal nicht was zu beobachten haben.
Ja, ich hatte das aber für israelische Propaganda ehrlich gesagt, dass ich glaube nicht, dass sie so schnell abhauen. Also, naja, gut, also jedenfalls. Ja, also diese Gegend da ist hochgradig spannend. Und das erklärt halt auch zum Beispiel so, wieso der, ja, also die Ägypten halt auch so wichtig ist. Also der Suos-Kanal, der Sinai sind halt irgendwie extrem neuralgische Punkte, so genau die Schildstelle, zwischen Asien, Afrika, Europa so. Und wer dieses Land beherrscht, der beherrscht da halt eine ganze Menge.
Na und der Nil, das wollen wir nicht verschweigen.
Na klar, der Nil ist natürlich ein wesentlicher Wirtschaftsfaktor und ist halt noch ein großes Land. Also insofern ist, also in Ägypten geht es sozusagen schon um was. Also es ist halt nicht irgendwie wie andere länder, wo halt irgendwie, die halt irgendwie gerade mal so klar kommen oder so, sondern Ägypten hat halt echt Potenzial und hat geostrategisch extrem günstig und extrem wichtig gelegen. Und für viele länder ist das halt von sehr großer bedeutung. Und nach dem frieden, nach dem Jankipur-Krieg ist de facto Ägypten auch ein, ja, wenigstens passiver verbündeter Israels gewesen. Es gibt da seit langem intensive Geheimdienst-Austauscher.
Na über die Amis eben, ne?
Ne, auch direkt. Also der jetzige Geheimdienstminister, der auch mal so immer...
Der neue vizepräsident, ja.
Der jetzige vizepräsident, stimmt. Der jetzige vizepräsident, ehemalige Geheimdienstminister, oder wahrscheinlich ist er immer noch Geheimdienstminister, der ist auch schon seit sehr vielen Jahren im Amt und der ist halt tatsächlich der, einer der wichtigsten Gesprächspartner der Israelis in der Gegend. Über den regeln sie da halt auch einfach Sachen, die sie halt nicht selber regeln können, also wenn sie da halt auch hier Probleme haben. Und mit dem diskutieren sie dann halt eben auch diese Geschichten, zum Beispiel halt über die ägyptische Abregelung des Gaza-Streifens Richtung Ägypten, ist das, wo diese Schmuggel-Tunnel sind, die wir auch gelähentlich schon mal erwähnt hatten. Und so. Also es ist halt schon so, dass Ägypten ist halt für die Israelis, sag ich mal, so eine stabile Flanke gewesen, wo sie sich eigentlich nicht weiter drum kümmern mussten, weil klar war, da ist alles geregelt, da passiert nichts weiter. So, das war sozusagen die sichere Front, sodass sie halt irgendwie Zeit hatten, sich halt irgendwie um den Lübarnot zu kümmern. Und dass es jetzt plötzlich eben nicht mehr sicher ist, sondern halt irgendwie unschar ist, was mit der nächsten Regierung ist, das trifft sie halt extrem hart. Also das ist halt schon so ein Ding.
Auch die Amis sind total kopflos, wenn du mal die beobachtest, was die da machen.
Also dass die Israelis halt irgendwie so offen sagen, dass sie irgendwie den Mubarakter als verbündeten betrachten und irgendwie, dass der bitte mal im Amt bleiben soll, das kann ich ja noch verstehen.
Das hat auch eine Woche gedauert, bis sie sich dazu hingerissen haben.
Nee, das haben sie schon echt schnell gesagt. Das war relativ zügig.
Also das sie gesagt haben, dass die Regime stabilität sicher sei, das sei ihnen wichtig. Aber dass sie den Mubarakter namentlich erwähnen, das hat eine Weile gedauert. Ich meine, Ägypten ist ja auch ein muslimisches Land. Und das ist nicht unbedingt ein Ritterschlag für ein muslimisches Land.
Ich glaube, da ging es ihnen eher um die internationalen Supporter und vor allen Dingen um die Amis. Am ende hängt es halt daran, was die Amis tun.
Die Amis haben die Stabilität des Ägypten im grunde gekauft. Die haben nämlich seit vielen Jahren, geben die denen wirklich großzügig Militärhilfe. Das fing an nach dem Yom Kippur-Krieg. Vorher war Ägypten eher mit der Sowjetunion verbandelt. Damals haben die Amis das übernommen. Und die geben...
75 haben es gekauft, ja.
Die kriegen jedes Jahr 1,3 milliarden. Das ist nur die Militärhilfe.
Das ist die offizielle Militärhilfe.
Dazu kommen noch normale Entwicklungshilfe, die natürlich auch... Das war mal eine Sendung zu machen, wie Entwicklungsoberfunktionen...
Ja, stimmt. Da müssen wir uns auch mal jemanden einladen. Ich hab da schon eine idee. Also am ende ist es so, dass die Schätzungen sind so irgendwie so zwischen 3 und 4 milliarden Dollar, gehen jedes Jahr von Amiland nach Ägypten. Also als Kaufpreis für die Stabilitäter.
Und die lassen auch ihre Militärhardware in Ägypten, also jetzt nicht die brandneueste, aber so die Abrams-Tanks, also Panzer zum Beispiel, werden in Ägypten in Lizenz gefertigt. Und Ägypten hat die siebtgrößte stehende Armee der Welt. Also das ist durchaus auch ein sehr militarisiertes Land.
Das ist jetzt auch wichtig, natürlich, weil die...
Was eigentlich kein gutes Zeichen ist, wenn da gerade mal eine Revolution losgeht. Das ist eigentlich kein gutes Zeichen.
Da kommen wir natürlich jetzt noch im Detail drauf, wer da welche Rolle spielt.
Zum Vergleich vielleicht noch, wie viel Israel kriegt. Die kriegen offiziell 1,8 milliarden. Aber das ist auch nur inoffiziell. Unter Bush ist es dann auf 3 milliarden erhöht worden, unter Clinton auf 2,4. Also auch in der Größenordnung, aber natürlich noch deutlich mehr geht an Israel. Aber man sieht den Stellenwert von Ägypten an diesen Zahlen. Das ist kein normaler verbündeter für die Amerikaner, sondern das lassen die sich richtig was kosten. Und da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, gut, Ägypten als Land ist wichtig, aber wieso haben die eigentlich diesen Mubarak da drin gelassen?
Ja, Mubarak war ja immer der verbündete der Amerikaner, nachdem die Ägypter die Russen absolviert haben und die Amerikaner sich da reingekauft haben, haben sie damit sich Stabilität in der Region erkauft. Das heißt also, sie haben dafür gesorgt, dass nun die Regierungsverwaltung nicht vielleicht so ganz demokratisch und irgendwie mit den Menschenrechten haben sie auch nicht immer so ganz direkt gehabt. Aber es war zumindest an dieser neuerischen Stelle, wie ich schon erwähnt, an der schönen Stelle zwischen den Kontinenten, immerhin eine stabile Regierung.
Vielleicht haben sie sich auch gedacht, dass wenn wir so viel Schmiergeld zahlen, dann werden die auf unserer Seite bleiben. Also, dass der Mubarak nicht nur durch seinen Charme im Amt bleibt, hat sich relativ schnell gezeigt. Der hat 1981 übernommen und ab 1982 gab es dann Notstandsgesetze, mit denen er sich seitdem an der Macht hält. Also, ziemlich direkt nach der Machtübernahme hat er angefangen, dafür zu sorgen, dass er wiedergewählt wird.
Gibt es da so Diktatoren-Training eigentlich so, also haben die da so?
Ja, in Amerika gibt es diese School of the Americas.
Aber die ist eigentlich eher mehr für Lateinamerika, die sowas auch so eine...
Ja, da wird der Mubarak nicht gewesen sein.
School of the Arabs oder sowas haben.
Na, wer weiß. Na, das sind ja eigentlich eher traditionelle Monarchien. Die brauchen kein Training der Amis.
Stimmt, du meinst, die haben ja ihre eigene Ausbildung für.
Ja, na, wie sieht es denn mit den Alternativen aus? Das ist eigentlich das Hauptargument für Mubarak gewesen.
Ja, stimmt. Also klar ist ja, dass die Ägypten als islamisches Land ist natürlich aus Sicht der Amis immer von einer Übernahme durch die Islamisten bedroht. Und natürlich aus der Sicht der Israelis auch. Und die haben, also in Ägypten gibt es schon ja seit sehr langer Zeit die muslimbrüderschaft oder Muslim Brotherhood. Eine ja, islamische, manche sagen auch islamistische Gruppe, die ja so ein Mittelding zwischen der politischen Partei, einer Gewerkschaft, einer Sozialvereinigung ist. Also das ist halt ja in diesem Kulturkreis nicht so ganz direkt zu trennen. Die halt ja einen, sagen wir mal, sehr stark sozial konservatives Programm haben. Also die sind halt so, hier würde man vielleicht sagen, so der äußere rechte Rand der bayerischen Bergdorf-CSU wäre wahrscheinlich damals so gleichbar.
Also ich zitiere mal den ersten Satz der Gründungsgeschichte. Die muslimen brüder wurden im Jahre 1928 von Hassan Albaner zusammen mit sechs Arbeitern der Suez-Kanal-Gesellschaft als Reaktion auf die Zusammenarbeit des ausmarnischen Reiches und dem britischen Kolonialismus in Ägypten gegründet. Ja, das kommt von da. Und die haben also unter anderem so Dinge gefordert, wie dass man die Scharia einführen soll, was eigentlich heute so ein bisschen Beigeschmack hat, aber historisch gesehen eigentlich die Grundlage der Gesetze von vielen ländern in der Gegend ist. Also das ist nicht unbedingt eine radikale forderung an sich.
Was man halt sehen muss, ist, dass der, also innerhalb des gesellschaftlichen Klimas da, das ja durch große soziale Ungerechtigkeiten herkennzeichnet ist, vermischen sich da natürlich religiöse ideen und ideen sozialer Gerechtigkeit ziemlich deutlich und dadurch, dass die Eliten in diesen ländern ja häufiger auch nun ja ihren Wohlstand halt auch relativ unverhüllter Schautragen aus mal neutral zu formulieren, bilden sich da natürlich halt auch massive soziale widersprüche, die ja dann eben ihren Ausdruck ungefähr finden müssen und die Organisationen brauchen und denen, denen sie halt reflektiert werden. Und nun religiöser Konservatismus, der halt eben doch sozial konservativ ist, im Sinne halt irgendwie die sünde etwas eingrenzen oder halt verbieten oder halt Hand abschlagen oder steinigen oder dergleichen Dinge mehr, findet dementsprechend heute auch Anklang, weil es halt eben eine radikale idee ist, eine Alternative ist zu den offensichtlich doch verkommenen, westlich orientierten Eliten. Und zumindest irgendwie, was man sich auch vergegenwärtigen muss, die haben eine enorme Jugendarbeitslosigkeitszahl. Also es ist halt so, dass da richtig viele Jugendliche arbeitslos sind und auch keinerlei Aussicht auf irgendeinen sinnvollen Job haben, außer vielleicht irgendwie die fladenbecker beim Falafelmann so.
Naja, also wir reden ja auch von den 30er-, 40er-, 50er-Jahren, wo man eigentlich ganz gut sehen konnte, dass das westliche modell auch nicht funktioniert. Das Elend vom Zweiten Weltkrieg war noch nicht lange zurück. Und also bei Wikipedia heißt es, dass die, um ein bisschen einzugrenzen, was die so tun, dass die eigene Maschinen hatten, das ist klar, eigene Krankenhäuser, eigene Fabriken, Schulen. Also das ist schon so ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Ding. Genau. Und nicht nur, wir sind jetzt in einer Protestbewegung.
Nee, nee, es ist tatsächlich der Versuch halt, eine religiös fundierte, motivierte Gegenbewegung zu machen. Also gab in Deutschland, gab es ja ähnliche Ansätze, wenn man es so ganz entfernt vergleicht, mit den religiösen Stiftungen, die ja eigene Siedlungen gebaut haben, eigene Fabriken gegründet haben. Also versucht haben, einfach eine Autarkie von der als verkommen empfundenen normalen Gesellschaft zu bilden. Und eben auf der Basis hier von christlicher Religiosität und genau dasselbe gab es da auch nur, dass dieses modell da eben nicht gestorben ist. Also auch die Hamas zum Beispiel ist ja genauso aufgebaut und die Hisbollah ja auch. Die sind ja eben nicht eine Partei, wie man sie hier kennt, sondern es ist halt alles. Es ist ein Business-Enterprise, die haben Krankenhäuser, die haben Schulen, versuchen halt irgendwie gewerkschaftsähnliche Funktionen wahrzunehmen. Das kann man so also mit normalen westlichen Partei- oder Bewegungsstrukturen halt nur sehr schwer vergleichen, weil es diese Strukturen in dieser Form hier so nicht mehr richtig gibt. Also Bewegungen, die halt einfach einen holistischen Ansatz fahren und sagen, okay, wir müssen uns von der als verderbt oder falsch empfundenen Welt abkapseln, indem wir unsere eigene Art des Wirtschaftens bauen und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Wahrscheinlich sollten wir hier sowas auch mal wieder bauen, nur vielleicht nicht auf religiöser Grundlage, sondern halt einfach auf Hackergrundlage. Vielleicht zum Beispiel auf der Basis der Hackerethik. Das ist nicht so eine schlechte idee.
Also historisch gesehen gab es jedenfalls relativ schnell Spannung zu Nasser, der eher einen säkulären Ansatz vor ist. Er ist heute zwar noch 90 Prozent muslimisch, aber gilt auch als relativ säkulärer Staat.
Was nichts zuletzt mit der Armee zu tun hat.
Also Nasser hat jedenfalls die muslimbrüderschaft dann verbieten lassen, und seit 1954, also schon relativ lange hier. Und die haben dann einen Anschlag auf jeden Fall übt, der aber fehl geschlagen hat, ohne irgendwas zu bewirken. Aber man sieht, es gab da Spannung.
Aber seitdem ist halt die, seit diesem Anschlag, ist halt die Feinschaft des Militärs und des Sicherheitsapparates zur muslimbrüderschaft doch sehr ausgeprägt. Und die gehen da halt in keiner Weise zimperlich vor. Also es ist halt so, dass die, also die verschwinden die halt schon mal so richtig und werden irgendwie ermordet und gefoltert und wiedergefunden. Also es ist halt nicht so, dass die da so viel zu lachen haben. Und die haben natürlich halt irgendwie ihre verbündeten mit, also auch Richtung Palästinense und sind im Zweifel auch die Ansprechpartner für andere islamische Strömungen in dieser Region. Und aus den radikaleren Ecken dieser muslimbrüderschaft sind dann halt auch irgendwie Al-Qaeda und ähnliche Gruppierungen, die sich da bedient haben. Und da, also zum Beispiel hier der, wie hieß er, Zawahiri, der lange Zeit als einer der vielen rechten hände von Osama bin laden handelt wurde. Nee, ich glaube, der zweite war der Erste oder so. Der stammte halt eben auch aus dieser muslimbruderhood-ecke. Und seitdem haben die Amis da halt auch so ein gewisses rotes Tuch, was wiederum halt auch erklärt, warum die halt eben so an diesem Mürbarak festgehalten haben oder auch immer noch festhalten. Weil sie halt einfach Schiss haben, dass Ägypten halt zu einem islamistischen Staat wird.
Das wissen wir ja seit dem Iran, wie das laufen kann.
Genau. Interessant war, ich hab da ein bisschen gelesen, wie so die westliche Wahrnehmung des Umsturzes im Iran damals war gegen den Schar. Das war ja sehr interessant. Das ist ja nicht so, dass sie direkt losfingen mit ein toller Komini legt den Schar flach. sondern es war so, dass der auch erst mal aussah wie eine westlich, also von westlichen idealen getriebene Revolution gegen den Schar. Und die Analysten im Westen haben alle lange Zeit nicht gesehen, dass da im Hintergrund halt irgendwie diese Komini-Bewegungen war, die halt einfach den, sozusagen erst mal die haben machen lassen. Und das lag unter anderem daran, dass die einfach keinen Leuten hatten, die Farsi sprachen.
Das Problem gibt es ja immer noch.
Also mittlerweile haben sie wahrscheinlich ein paar mehr Leute, die halt einfach in der Lage sind, sich mit den Ägyptern nativ zu verständigen und auch vielleicht mal irgendwie Al-Jazeera arabisch zu sehen. Aber damals war es halt so, dass die, also wahrscheinlich genau dasselbe Fakt wie mit diesen Twitter- und facebook-revolutionsrede rein, dass es halt einfach genau der Teil ist, den man sehen kann. Also der halt einfach in der, in konform zu westlichen Betrachtungsweisen ist. Und insofern ist halt eben doch sehr spannend, dass natürlich die Wahrnehmung von so einer großen Protestbewegung wie in Ägypten ist natürlich zwangsläufig immer geprägt von dem, was wir sehen und verstehen können.
Aber, um noch mal klar zu sagen, die muslimbrüderschaft stellt die Opposition. Also im Wesentlichen.
Also wenn es Wahlen geben würde, würden sie wahrscheinlich so was wie zwischen 20 und 30 Prozent kriegen.
Naja.
So in der großen Klasse.
Aber ich mein, wir reden hier von der Diktatur. Das ist die Opposition. Also der Rest geht im Wesentlichen.
Nee, die säkuläre Opposition ist auch schon nicht so wenig. Und zumal die halt eben doch in den Großstädten ist und stark von der Mittelschicht vertreten.
Moment, Moment. Also eins der Probleme ist, dass die offiziell immer noch nicht geduldet sind. Und dass die deswegen bei der Wahl eben nicht als muslimenbruderschaft antreten, sondern als Unabhängige. Das heißt, wenn man sich die Opposition ansieht im Moment, ja, da gibt es halt eine Menge Unabhängige. Wahrscheinlich sind nicht alle von denen muslimenbruderschaft. Aber es ist schon so, dass es die größte Oppositionskraft ist im Land.
Also die größte in einer Organisation strukturierte.
Genau. Und das heißt, im grunde gehen die westlichen Beobachter seit vielen Jahren davon aus, wenn der Mubarak irgendwann abtritt, dann fällt das Land an die Islamisten. Und das ist der Grund, warum die Amis eben so viel in Security-Technologie und Militär-Hardware darin exportieren. Und warum wir westlichen länder, denen auch die Telco-Hardware gegeben haben, um ihr Internet zu zensieren und so weiter, dass dann wir den ja verkauft. Ja, den Punkt will ich hier mal nochmal hervorheben.
Offensichtlich wird er ja nicht bedient.
Ja, nein, das gehört natürlich auch immer dazu. Aber das ist ja gut an der Stelle. Ich sag das ja auch schon seit vielen Jahren. Unsere beste Verteidigung gegen den Unterdrückungs- und Überwachungsstaat ist die Inkompetenz der anderen Seite. Wenn sie wüssten, was sie tun, dann wären wir echt am Arsch. Gut, jedenfalls, also die muslimbrüderschaft ist der Teil der ägyptischen Opposition, der den Amerikanern und Israelis genug Angst gemacht hat, dass sie lieber den Mubarak imamt haben als die. Weil die einfach gedacht haben, oh Gott, das wird ja noch viel schlimmer ohne den. Und inzwischen sieht es halt so aus, als wenn das nicht unbedingt wahr ist. Also die muslimbrüderschaft ist sich natürlich dessen bewusst, wie sie im Ausland gesehen wird, und hat sich bemüht, bei den Demonstrationen nicht offen mitzumachen. Also die laufen zwar mit, aber verkleidet.
Also in westlicher Kleidung waren zumindest die Sachen, die berichtet wurden, dass die muslimbrüder aufgefordert werden, halt in westlicher Kleidung da irgendwie zu erscheinen. Also interessant fand ich aber eben auch, dass so die Berichte halt darüber, wie sich das im Alltag auswirkt. Also dadurch, dass die muslimbrüder halt eben da auch Infrastruktur haben, also halt Bäckereien haben und so, dass sie halt in der Lage sind, diese Demonstration auch logistisch zu versorgen. Also das ist halt wirklich so eine Sache, die man halt immer, also man sollte nie den Wert von eigener Infrastruktur unterschätzen. Das ist eine ganz, ganz wichtige Lehre aus dieser Geschichte.
Gut, das wissen wir schon seit YouTube, ne?
Ja.
Infrastruktur schaffen ist immer eine gute idee, auch wenn du kein Geld machst. Also die Muslim-Buddhaschaft hat jedenfalls kürzlich überzeugt oder überrascht, sagen wir mal, dadurch, dass sie offenen el-baradei supportet hat, der ja kein Islamist ist, sondern eher so ein moderater westlich erzogener präsidentschaftskandidat, der ursprüngliche präsident der IAA, der Atomenenergie-Kommission. Und der hat sich jetzt das Gespräch gebracht für die Nachfolger-Regierung und die muslimbruderschaft unterstützt eben und sagt der Presse dazu, die ihre religiösen Ziele gelten zwar immer noch, aber die würden jetzt auf Sparflamme laufen. Wichtig sei erstmal eine Demokratie jemand zu etablieren.
Na klar, weil sie halt natürlich wissen, dass sie halt gewinnen. Na ja, ob sie gewinnen, ist nicht klar. Aber auf jeden Fall sind sie halt eine hinreichend große Macht, dass sie unter demokratischen Verhältnissen da, ja also eine islamisch geprägte Demokratie wäre dann wohl tatsächlich das Resultat da. Das ist halt eine Sache, auf die der Westen offensichtlich nicht so richtig Lust hat und die Israelis natürlich überhaupt gar nicht. Was halt auch erklärt, warum die Israelis sich halt irgendwie so aus dem Fenster hängen für den Mubarak. Das ist ja gerade so eine der peinlicheren Geschichten.
Vor allem für den Mubarak auch peinlich, weil das ist ja nun ein Nieschuss. Und auch mit freunden wie Israelis, die der Presse erklärt, dass sie dich gerne im Amt halten möchten.
Also brauchst du keine feinde mehr als staatspräsident einer islamischen Stadt. Die Opposition hat ja da auch den Cleveridge-Hachzug begangen. Zum einen gab es Nachrichten darüber, dass die Israelis drei Transportflugzeuge voller frischer Trinkgaskanaten nach Kareo geschickt haben gestern. Keine Ahnung, lässt sich das nicht verifizieren.
Na ja, schlimmer wird es nicht, als Israel hilft.
Dann kam die Nachricht, dass sie gesagt haben, Israel bietet dem Mubarak im Zweifel Asyl an. Das war der absolute P.A.-Sport.
Davon erholt sich niemand.
Na ja, die interessante Frage, die wir nun schon so ein bisschen angerissen haben, ist so, warum zensiert denn, also warum belassen sie es denn nicht so ein bisschen bei Überwachung und ein bisschen selektiven Sperren, warum kommen sie mit dieser großen Keule und sperren das ganze Internet in Ägypten so. Und die, also meine Theorie ist ja, dass es folgendermaßen aussieht. Wenn man so eine Diktatur hat, dann möchte man natürlich eigentlich wissen, wer die Oppositionellen sind und wenn man das dann weiß, dann kann man die halt entweder diskutieren oder Mundtritt machen oder foltern oder einen Knast sperren. Also jedenfalls irgendwie einzeln sozusagen aufreiben.
Na vor allem in Einzelnen das Gefühl geben, dass du sie einzeln beobachtest.
Genau.
Also so eine Revolution funktioniert ja nur in der Anonymität. Wenn du das Gefühl hast, du bist Teil einer großen Menge, die da rennt. Wenn der Staat das irgendwie schafft, dir das Gefühl zu geben, du als Einzelner wirst hier beobachtet und wir wissen, wer du bist.
Und wir kriegen dich dran.
Und wir kriegen dich eventuell dran, dann ist das gescheitert natürlich. Und insofern ist es eigentlich ungeschickt, das Internet abzudrehen. Das ist sogar vollständig kontraproduktiv.
Was das aber wahrscheinlich heißt, ist, dass eben genau dieser Masseneffekt schon eingetreten ist. Und da sind wir wieder bei dieser Geschichte von dieser sogenannten Twitter- oder Facebook-Revolution. Der Punkt ist, da ist natürlich ein Kern Wahrheit daran, aber der ist halt ein anderer, als er allgemein gesehen wird. Wir müssen einfach damit leben, dass es große Demografien da draußen gibt. Die benutzen halt kein E-Mail mehr, die benutzen halt Facebook. Und die benutzen halt einfach Facebook-Messaging für ihre normale Alltagskommunikation. Und wenn irgendwas los ist, ich mach das halt bitter, aber so ist es halt, und wenn halt irgendwas los ist, wie zum Beispiel Proteste und dergleichen Dinge mehr, dann benutzen die halt Facebook. Und der Effekt...
Der in den terminkalender.
Ja, der Effekt, den darf man nicht unterschätzen. Also wenn er die Proteste, also ich hab mir das mal ein bisschen mit Google Translate versucht anzugucken, was da eigentlich passiert. Und die Proteste wurden da als Facebook-Events angekündigt. Und der größte, der in Kairo hatte 90.000 zugesagte Teilnehmer.
Ist natürlich für die Regierung perfekt, wenn du sehen kannst, wer da alles ansagt, hinzugehen eigentlich.
Ja, aber dann ist wahrscheinlich genau der Punkt überschritten, was sind 90.000 Leute, das kriegst du nicht mehr hin. Das ist für selbst, wenn du irgendwie...
So viele Polizisten haben die nicht, meinst du, dass sie jeden besuchen können?
Nee, das kriegen die einfach nicht mehr überwachungstechnisch, nicht mehr in den Griff. Also das auszuwerten. Also klar, kriegen sie die Daten auf die Platte geschrieben und so, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Aber das so auszuwerten, dass du da taktische Ergebnisse daraus ziehen kannst. Und wenn du irgendwann überschreitest halt den Punkt, wo du die noch alle festnehmen kannst.
Ja, na gut.
Weil da sind dann halt in Zweifel die kinder deiner Offiziere dabei.
Okay, aber warum machen die nicht einfach Facebook zu, sondern das Ganze Internet?
Na, das haben sie ja versucht. Sie haben ja zuerst, sind sie ja losgegangen und im ersten Schritt und haben die APIs von Facebook, Twitter, Bambusa, den Oppositionszeitungen noch so ein paar große Webforum gesperrt.
Bisschen Bambusa.
Auch so ein Social-Network-Webforums-Ding. Und der Effekt war halt einfach, dass die Leute drumherum gegangen sind. Und es ging halt, sie haben festgestellt, sie können es von den Telefonen aus noch klicken, weil die vergessen haben, die IPs von den APIs zu sperren, auf die die Applikationen gingen. Die waren halt noch offen. Dann haben wohl Twitter und Facebook angefangen, ein bisschen mit ihren IPs zu spielen. Weil eine IP keine dns-blockade hat. Weil sie sich offensichtlich dachten, so DNS kommen Leute zu einfach drumherum. Benutzen wahrscheinlich sowieso alle den Google-DNS, weil der DNS von ihrem ISP-Scheiße ist. Dann haben sie halt die IPs gesperrt. Das hat halt nicht funktioniert. Und am nächsten Schritt sind sie hingegangen und haben halt den einzelnen ISPs die DSL-Router, also die Access-Router gesperrt. Das heißt, du konntest die Router in den Netzwerken noch pingen, aber nicht mehr die Home-Router. Also den Konzentrator haben sie halt offensichtlich gesperrt.
Aber auch nicht nur für die, von denen sie wussten, dass sie irgendwie zu Facebook gehen, sondern für alle. Weil da war dann auch zu spät mit der Auswertung. Ja, da war so das Stasi-Problem irgendwie. Du hast irgendwie zwar alle Daten, aber du hast nicht mehr die Manpower, um da durchzugehen.
Also da tritt dann halt eben auch dieser Netzwerkeffekt ein. Wenn du siehst, da sind schon 5000 Leute, die mutig waren und gesagt haben, ey, da geh ich hin. So, dann klickst du auch mal eher drauf und sagst, ja, da komm ich auch hin. Das ist sozusagen diese virtuelle Schwelle, dass du irgendwie auf die Straße gehst, ist halt irgendwie relativ schnell überschritten.
Naja, und es gibt auch umgekehrt den Effekt, wenn du dich da einmal committed hast, dann weißt du, wenn du dir jetzt nicht durchziehst, dann hast du verkackt. Wenn der Mobarak im Abend bleibt, dann wird das nicht ausgewertet.
Das ist genau der Effekt, der jetzt eintritt.
Und jetzt müssen die auch weiter machen.
Die Leute wissen jetzt, dass sie, also das war übrigens auch bei diversen Twitterern und Bloggern zu lesen, die gerade im Ausland sind und berichten von ihren freunden da, die sagen, naja, ich hab jetzt irgendwie keine Wahl mehr, ich muss jetzt so radikal sein, wie ich nur sein kann, weil der muss jetzt da weg, sonst kann ich nie wieder nach Hause fahren. Das ist so ein Effekt, der jetzt halt eintritt. Und dieser Facebook- und Twitter-Effekt, der da entstanden ist, der ist jetzt halt nichts mehr besonderes. Deswegen sind Unsinn da, von Twitter oder Facebook-Revolution zu reden, das sind halt die Alltags-Kommunikationsmittel der Kids da draußen. Und die benutzen sie halt für alles, was ihnen unter die Finger kommt, ob es nur die Partie-Einladung ist oder halt die Einladung zur Demonstration oder Revolution oder was auch immer so. Na gut, und nachdem dieses IP-Blocking, also bzw. dass der DSL-Router-Blocking auch nicht so richtig funktioniert hat, weil zum Beispiel dann halt immer noch die ganzen Firmen, die waren halt immer noch online.
Na, hast du dir ein Update von heute Morgen mitgekriegt, dass die dann die Fido-Mailboxen wieder hochgefahren haben? Das war nicht überhaupt die schönste Geschichte überhaupt. Weißt du, wo ich es dachte? Ach ja, die Zeit erinnere ich mich auch noch so. Und das stimmt natürlich, weißt du, wir haben ja noch diese ganzen uralten Scheiß-Technologien, die haben wir alle noch im Keller, die Leute, die damals aktiv waren. Der erste Schritt war, dass die Leute angefangen haben, ihre WLANs wieder aufzumachen.
Die haben die WLANs aufgemacht und gesagt, hier irgendwie...
Wenn ihr euch hier auf einer Demo verabreden wollt, dann nutzt auch mein WLAN dafür. Also das finde ich überhaupt den schönsten Effekt an so einer Zensur, dass es eben nicht dazu geführt hat, was es normalerweise tut.
Dass die Leute eingeschüchtert sind, sondern das wird einfach so ein...
Na, auch zu isolieren, dieses Gefühl, du bist jetzt isoliert, der Staat hat gesehen, dass du ein gefährder bist und du wirst jetzt hier behandelt. Im Gegenteil, es hat dazu geführt, dass die Leute sich gegen dich zusammentun. Es war voll der Schuss in den Ofen. Und das muss auch zu dieser Panikreaktion geführt haben, dass die jetzt eben ganz Internet abgedreht haben. Also anders ist das nicht zu erklären.
Vermutlich, ja. Und wahrscheinlich war es so eine Panikreaktion, die dann wiederum aber auch dazu geführt hat, dass sich noch mehr Leute auf die Straße getrieben haben, weil die Leute dann plötzlich nicht mehr auf Twitter und Facebook...
Die Frauen konnten nicht mehr so auf Warcraft spielen.
Sie konnten halt einfach nicht mehr im Bildschirm sehen, was los ist. Die ganzen Kids, die zocken, gingen halt nicht mehr so.
Die Kids, die jahrelang trainiert haben, wie man sich gegen eine Übermacht an wohlbewaffneten Monstern wehrt, sind dann auf die Straße gelaufen.
Sind dann Bosse killen gegangen. Ja, also gut, ich weiß nicht, ob es so war, aber zumindest einige von den bildern sahen schon so aus. Diese schwarmartigen Steinwurf-Angriffe, die sahen schon ziemlich gewohlt trainiert aus.
Vor allem haben sie im Ausland das Image total getötet, weil wenn du das Internet abdrehst, gibst du zu, hier ist gerade eine Revolution. So alles andere kannst du sagen, ja technisches Problem haben wir aber eigentlich noch im Griff. Aber wenn du Internet abdrehst, dann ist irgendwie allen beobachter klar, da ist gerade eine Revolution.
Sie haben es halt zur Revolution geadelt, das kann man nicht anders sagen. Also interessant fand ich ja, dass sie eben genau diese Überlegung, die halt alle anderen bisher hatten, wir lassen das mal laufen und überwachen noch eine runde. Wie zum Beispiel selbst in Georgien hat Putin dafür gesorgt, dass das Netz weiter lief. Also ich meine, böse Zungen behaupten, er hätte das getan, damit wir diese bilder von ihm schlips gekriegt haben. Damit wir weiter dem Sackaj Willi zugucken können, wie er an seinem Schlips kaut aus seiner Webkamera.
Aber das war es doch wert, oder?
Ja, aber zum damaligen Zeitpunkt hatte zumindest ich die Theorie, dass nachdem die Russen beim Angriff auf Georgien, also beim Rückschlag gegen Georgien, also dass dann klar war, man dreht das Internet nicht mehr ab, weil es zu wertvoll ist, was man an Informationen gewinnen kann. Aber offensichtlich gibt es Situationen, wo das nicht so ist. Nämlich, wenn halt richtig doll viele Leute... Dann ist offensichtlich irgendwann ist dann die Dynamik für so einen Diktator da, dass man dann sagt, okay, wir müssen jetzt abdrehen, um da wenigstens mal so ein bisschen aufs Bremspedal zu treten, weil jetzt irgendwie die Dynamik von Organisationsentwicklung getroffen wird.
Na, wobei das lief auch damals einfach zu gut gegen Georgien. Ich erinnere mich, dass deren Regierungswebseiten down waren und dass sie dann einen Blog aufgemacht haben, irgendwie bei blogger.com oder... Und da ist es so richtig oberpeinlich und das lässt du natürlich online. Natürlich, damit alle sehen können, so sieht eine Regierung aus, die nichts mehr im Griff hat. Aber ich meine, hier wird man sich halt nicht gegen die Russen, sondern gegen die eigene Bevölkerung. Das ist eben schon nochmal was anderes.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Naja, und die interessante Frage ist ja nun, wie geht das halt weiter? Na ja, also welche Auswirkungen hat das Ganze? Und Sie haben ja offensichtlich versucht, die schlimmsten Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft ein bisschen zu begrenzen, indem Sie den einen ASP leben lassen haben. Nämlich NOA.
Weil bei dem die Börse gehostet wird.
Da ist nicht nur die Börse. Da sind auch, wenn man sich diesen kundenliste anguckt, sind da halt auch sehr, sehr viele große Firmen auch westliche Unternehmen, die darüber ihre Logistik machen.
Wie wichtig ist denn diese Börse für Afrika? Ist sie überregional wertvoll? Wichtig?
Kann ich nicht sagen. Aber auf jeden Fall passiert da schon eine Menge trade. Also ich meine, wenn die 500 Millionen Dollar pro Tag abziehen können aus dieser Börse, dann muss da wohl schon ein bisschen Volumen vorhanden sein. Weil so die Zahl, wie viel gerade an Flucht passiert aus Ägypten, an Investments.
Dabei ist das total bescheuert. Das ist genau der Moment, wo du mehr Kohle...
Naja, noch vielleicht nicht. Also momentan will man gerade noch ein bisschen warten.
Aber warten jedenfalls mit Optionen auf reingehen und nicht abziehen.
Aber die Börse ist gerade sowieso außer Betrieb. Aber die spannende Frage ist halt, ich glaube eben nicht, dass nur wegen der Börse online gelassen wurde, sondern dass es da andere gründe gibt, nämlich zum einen halt die Logistik. Kann auch sein, dass zum Beispiel die Logistik des Kanals darüber läuft.
Vielleicht hosten die ihre eigene Abhörscheiße bei Noah.
Vielleicht ist es so stumpf.
Das behörden-intranet, wir wissen schon.
Vielleicht ist es auch so stumpf, dass das Online-Formular für die SUS-Kanal-Passage da läuft.
Oh ja, irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung, also jedenfalls muss irgendwas sein, was halt einfach den, also Wertmachte dieses Ding...
Was nicht optional ist.
Ja, genau. Und also heute gab es irgendwie Berichte darüber, dass sie bei NOAA auch anfangen, mit dem DNS zu spielen, also dass sie da DNS-Filtering betreiben. Ja, keine Ahnung, jedenfalls ist das eine der wirklich spannenden Fragen, warum sind die dann noch online so. Was ich noch interessant finde, ist, dass diese Internet-Zensur sorgt ja eigentlich dafür, dass es eine Informations-Verknappung gibt. Also zusammen mit der Fernseh-Zensur. Also die Fernseh-Zensur ist ja so, die haben ja Al-Jazeera vom Satelliten geschopst. Daraufhin hat Al-Jazeera sich einen neuen Satelliten gesucht, der aber auf der gleichen Position liegt. Genau, sie sind halt von Nilsat auf den Atlanticboard 4a gewechselt, um ihren Kanal weiter online zu halten. Und dann gab es jetzt aber wieder Berichte, dass sie da zumindest per störsender gestört werden oder sonst irgendwie versucht wird, die da runterzuschubsen. Sie schulzen momentan im Scroller von Al-Jazeera, ist nur noch Hot-Bot und Arab-Sat. Also die Satelliten, für die man ein bisschen größere Schüsseln braucht.
Erklär doch mal, warum Egypten die überhaupt vom Nilsat schubsen konnte.
Ja, der Nilsat ist eine Dreierkonstellation aus drei Satelliten, die den Ägypten gehören und die sind primär darauf ausgerichtet, den nordafrikanischen Raum auszuleuchten und zwar mit einer sendeleistung, wo man halt eine 50-Zentimeter-Schlüssel in der Hauptausleuchtungszone braucht. Also eine sehr kleine Schüssel mit irgendwie so einem selbstgedengelten LNB vorne dran.
Kannst du auch einen Kochtopf nehmen, ja?
Nein, nicht ganz, aber so geht es schon so in die richtige Richtung. Also es ist halt irgendwie nicht besonders anspruchsvoll, die Empfangstechnik, die man da so braucht. Und Al-Jazeera war da natürlich drauf, weil sie halt damit ihre Zuschauerzahlen nach oben treiben konnten. Und das Broadcasting von Al-Jazeera, soweit ich verstanden habe, funktioniert so über Nilsat, oder funktionierte so über Nilsat, dass die ein Signal von einem anderen Siedling, ich glaube vom Arabsat, rebroadcasten darüber. Das heißt, es geht in Ägypten irgendwo runter über den Arabsat und wird von da wieder über den Nilsat rebroadcastet. Heißt also, um vom Nilsat die runterzuschubsen, mussten sie nichts weiter tun, als den Al-Jazeera nicht mehr einspeisen. Also die Ägypter mussten halt nicht mehr zum Nilsat hochschicken. Und...
Aber da sieht man, was für eine zentrale Rolle Ägypten spielt in der Infrastruktur von Afrika, ne?
Und die interessante Frage ist, über welchen Uplink feeden sie den Atlantic Bird? Müssen wir vielleicht nochmal nachgucken. Es könnte halt sein, dass sie sie vom Atlantic Bird runtergeschubsen haben, weil die Zugriff auf den Uplink haben. Also mit der zum Atlantic Bird hoch geht, wäre eine interessante Frage, kann ich nicht beantworten.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch so, dass Ägypten einfach eine riesige Wirtschaftsmacht ist in der Gegend. Und wenn die bei dem Betreiber hier von Atlantic Bird anrufen und sagen, wir ziehen unser Business ab.
Das ist eutelsatt. Also ich glaube, die sind...
Na ja, hör mal.
Na ja, also... Also es wäre jedenfalls auch ein Thema. Also wenn die Europäer sich da an der Zensur beteiligt hätten, das wäre schon ganz schön krass. Also das ist jedenfalls ein Thema, was wir irgendwie nochmal ausführlich klären müssen, ist, wie diese ganze Satelliten-Zensur funktioniert hat. Also das wäre für das Postmortem dieser Krise sicherlich eines der wichtigeren Themen halt, um mal zu gucken, wie funktioniert denn genau diese Satelliten-Zensur. Interessant war aber zu sehen, halt solange das noch lief und auch jetzt im Nachhinein war es ja so, dass die Ägypter haben ja versucht, die Arbeitsmöglichkeiten von Al-Jazeera massiv einzuschränken. Also die haben ja das Büro von Al-Jazeera in Cairo gestürmt und haben die Kamera vom Balkon runtergeholt. Also zwischenzeitlich hat Al-Jazeera keine Leute mehr auf der Straße gehabt, weil sie es zu gefährlich fanden. oder nur Leute, die halt irgendwie mit kleinen Kameras aus dem Auto gefilmt haben, weil sie halt irgendwie zu viele Journalisten verloren haben, sind sechs oder so, sind verhaftet worden. Also offensichtlich gezielt von ägyptischer Innenpolizei. Und die haben dann halt von ihrem Balkon runter. Der Balkon zeigt aber genau die größte Brücke von Cairo, was so die Lebensalter von Cairo ist.
Ach, da kommt dieses video her.
Und da kommen halt diese videos her mit diesen Autos, die da in die Menge rasen und diese ganzen Sachen. Das ist halt genau von dieser Brücke gefilmt. Und das hat die Ägypter offensichtlich richtig angeödet. Und interessanterweise war die ägyptische Regierung. Und die Abschaltung kam dann, nachdem Al-Jazeera ein video gezeigt hat aus dem Leichenschauhaus von Cairo.
Ja, das ist aber auch nicht stilvoll.
Und zwar liegt das, soweit ich weiß, nur auf der arabischen Version. Also muss man halt auch immer sehen, dass die in der Regel die... Das arabische Al-Jazeera ist immer eine runde krasser als das englische. Also die zeigen dann halt auch schon mal so die Appenarme und irgendwie die richtig kaputten Leute, die halt während der englischen Version dann immer nur so mal jemand, der sich die Blut in den Stirn hält, kommt, zeigen sie die Opfer halt in der arabischen Version dann meistens halt nicht in der familienfreundlichen Schnittvariante. Und das meinten die Al-Jazeera-Mitarbeiter. Auf Twitter zumindest wäre wohl der Auslöser gewesen, dass sie halt im Leichen-Showhaus einfach die Opfer, also die Mengen an Opfern gezeigt haben, die da sich angehäuft haben, die halt da von den Sicherheitskräften getötet wurden.
Na wir haben ja auch ansonsten nur irgendwelche Gerüchtetweets, wo man auch nicht weiß. Es gab da zum Beispiel das Gerücht, dass irgendwie den Ärzten verboten worden sei, die Toten zu melden, die an Kugeln gestorben sind und so. Übrigens zu Al-Jazeera, warum ich grad so ein bisschen lachen musste, als es hieß zu gefährlich für Al-Jazeera, es gibt eine Dokumentation namens Control Room aus dem Jahr 2004 über Al-Jazeera, die kann ich nur wärmstens empfehlen. Da gibt es eine Szene, wo sie auf dem Dach von dem Hotel im Irak sitzen, was dann bombardiert wurde. Und da sind die Journalisten da sitzen. Und in dem Film geht es dann halt auch darum, wie der eben von den Amis dann gezielt ermordet wurde. Und sie interviewen eben den Chefredakteur von Al-Jazeera. Ist ein sehr beeindruckender Film. Sollen wir mal gucken, ob wir den irgendwo kriegen können. Und also, wenn dem Sinn, dass das zu gefährlich ist, dann wird man einfach richtig sein. Oh mein Gott.
Was dann halt passiert ist, nachdem Al-Jazeera mit dem Büro wurde ihnen halt auch der Uplink von Cairo aus plattgemacht. Also die haben... Naja, klar.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch der Grund, warum sie das Büro haben wollten.
Den Satelliten-Uplink aus Cairo raus, zurück nach Katar, wo ihre Zentrale ist. Den haben sie ihnen bei der Gelegenheit auch plattgemacht. Und was sie danach gemacht haben, war offensichtlich satellitendaten-modems zu benutzen. Also die live-kamera-bilder, die da kamen, da sieht man halt immer, dass die halt schon etwas hart encoded sind. Also ich würde mal so sagen...
Hart am Rand, ja.
So 140, 150 Kilobit oder so weit haben sie da als Streamer. Also immer wenn sie schwenken, werden die Klötzchen sehr viel größer, aber wenn sie so statisch auf dem Platz halten, dann geht es so halbwegs. Und also zwischenzeitlich hatte ich schon so dieses Gefühl, so dass die Leute da unten auf dem Platz, so haben wir live übertragen, von dem Traurierplatz da, ist diese Kamera, die diese Leute da gerade am Leben hält. Also wenn da nicht zugeguckt wird, wenn da nicht Leute hingucken, wenn da die Kamera draufzückt, dann rollen die da durch, ne? Und das ist dann schon eine echt dramatische Verantwortung, die du da so hast als fernsehsender, wenn du das Auge der Welt bist, was halt wieder dafür sorgt, dass irgendwie die Leute da nicht gemetzelt werden, das ist schon ganz schön krass so. Und als Sieger ist jetzt halt so im Kriegsberichterstattungsmodus.
Wir wollten auch nochmal würdigen, dass sie ihre Streamingleistung echt barbarisch hochgedreht haben, so mal eben über Nacht. Also die Shoot, die Zuschauerzahlen bei denen sind echt enorm explodiert in den letzten Tagen natürlich. Und die haben zwar zwei, drei kleine Problemchen gehabt, aber im Großen und Ganzen guckt da gerade die Welt zu und es ist nicht so, dass es einfach mal wirklich wegbricht unter der Last. Also da muss man schon sagen, die haben da gute Leute.
Ja, und die machen auch viele Sachen richtig. Also Al Jazeera zum Beispiel eine relativ große Creative Commons Library, wo sie halt ihr Raw-Material als Creative Commons zur Verfügung stellen von etlichen Sachen. Und dann kann man hinschreiben und sagen, das und das hätte ich gerne als Creative Commons. Und die schreiben dann tatsächlich zurück. Also ich hab's gerade probiert, mich interessierte genau diese, die hatten da so einen einzigen Beitrag zum Thema die Satellitenumschaltung. Und ja, die haben zurückgemeldet und gesagt, ja, hier, wo war denn der, suchen wir den raus. Das finde ich ja schon irgendwie großartig. Ich bekomme hier gerade die Meldung rein, dass nur jetzt auch offline ist. Und dass sie SMS plattgemacht haben. Interessant, okay. Also geht da offensichtlich weiter mit der Abschaltung.
Naja, aber da siehst du mal, wie verzweifelt die sind. Also eine Sache, die ich noch anmerken wollte, ist, man muss denen ja fast dankbar sein. Denn bei uns wäre Internet-Abschalten immer noch im Gespräch als Gesetz. Die bundesregierung hat ja darüber nachgedacht, ob sie sowas haben.
Diese Internet-Killswitch-Geschichte.
Ja, die wollten gerne ein Killswitch fürs Internet haben. Die idee kommt von Obama, dem friedensfürsten. Und die Amis haben sich ja auch nicht entblödet, da ausgerechnet jetzt dieses Gesetz zu bereden, ob sie nicht ein Killswitch brauchen, während gleichzeitig der Pressesprecher des Weißen Hauses der staubenden Presse erklärt, dass es ja ein Unrecht ist, wenn Ägypten das Internet abdreht. Also die laufen da auch mit Scheuklappen größeren Kaliber durch die Gegend. Und natürlich ist es bei uns auch Unrecht, wenn wir das Internet abdrehen. Man sieht ganz gut, in Ägypten, der einzige Anwendungsfall, wo man das mal braucht, ist, wenn eine Revolution ist und du bist ein Diktator, der sein Unrecht verstecken will. Es gibt keine legitimen gründe, warum man das Internet abschalten will. Das ist wie das Telefonnetz, ein Kommunikationsmittel und sollte ein Grundrecht für alle sein.
Interessant finde ich ja den Versuch, den sie gerade auf der UNO-Ebene treiben, um eine moralische Legitimierung für so eine Abschaltssysteme zu finden.
Und was haben sie bisher?
Das ist nicht so doof. Und zwar ist die idee zu sagen, naja, es gab schon Fälle, wo UNO-Truppen radiosender außer Betrieb genommen haben, und zwar in zum Beispiel Ruanda und ähnlichen Situationen, wo es um den Aufruf zum Genozid ging. Und da gibt es sozusagen so diskussionsrunden, in denen diskutiert wird, dass man ja möglicherweise, wenn halt so eine Situation sei, auch Internet zeitweise außer Betrieb nehmen müsse, um halt irgendwie Aufruf zum Genozid zu verhindern.
Na weißt du, wo an mich es erinnert? kinderpornos. Haben sie nach der größten Keule gesucht, die sie finden könnten, um ihren Scheiß da zu rechtfertigen. Na gegen Genozid kann doch wirklich keiner was sagen. Da muss man doch... Also ich glaube das nicht. Ich glaube nach wie vor Internet abdrehen ist nicht richtig.
Das ist natürlich ein Anrecht, so ich bin da...
Und da müssen wir gegenhalten und ich bin dem Mubarak-Verhalten dankbar, dass er uns jetzt Munition gegeben hat, mit der wir dagegen argumentieren können. Übrigens eine Sache, die mir immer wieder auffällt in dieser Zeit und die ich auch nochmal ansprechen will. Die ganzen paranoiden Wahnvorstellungen von früher, die sind heute Realität. Früher, wir reden ja, wir Hacker sind ja eigentlich schon immer so ein bisschen Ingenieure und denken über Rand, Corner-Cases und irgendwelche Anbindungen nach. Und was wäre denn, wenn sie das gegen uns tun? Und ein Teil davon klingt wie paranoide Wahnvorstellungen von irgendwelchen Berufsverfolgten. Und da war natürlich auch als bedrohungsmodell drin, da was machen, wenn wir das Internet abdrehen? Und da haben immer alle gelacht und gesagt, so ein Blödsinn, das würden die nie tun. Und heute sehen wir es einfach mal, das passiert. Und auch bei uns wird es diskutiert. Also das ist so und man muss da so früh wie möglich anfangen, das in seine Bedrohungsszenarien aufzunehmen, auch wenn es nicht so aussieht, als wäre die aktuelle Regierung da gefährdet. oder andersrum, es gibt ja auch die Argumentation, naja, aber unsere Regierung würde das ja nicht gegen uns benutzen. Ja, und das ist auch historisch falsch. Also das kann man an Holland gut sehen. Da ist nämlich die Quote der juden, die von den Nazis vernichtet wurden, am höchsten in Europa, weil die nämlich vor dem Einmarsch der Nazis bei ihren Volksbefragungen nach der Religionszügigkeit befragt haben. Und als die Nazis dann durchmarschiert sind, haben sie die Unterlagen gefunden und haben gesagt, oh ist ja toll, wir wissen genau, wen wir abholen müssen. Und so ist das, keine Daten aufheben, die man nicht braucht und immer von den paranoidesten Wahnvorstellungen ausgehen in Sachen Zukunft, die man finden kann.
Ja, dummerweise ist es mittlerweile mehrfach bestätigt, dass es so traurig das ist. Einzig sinnvoll vorgehend ist.
Und ich möchte auch noch sagen, die idee, dass es für zentrale kritische Infrastruktur sowas wie einen sicheren Hafen gibt irgendwo, ein Land, naja, die werden schon nichts Böses damit machen oder bei Ägypten hieß es halt immer, naja, das ist ja in der Gegend das stabilste Land. Ja, das sind die einzigen, wo wir nicht mehr mit der Revolution rechnen müssen. Und ich meine, man muss ja sagen, in den 80ern und 90ern im Vergleich, so besagen wir, Syrien und Libyen, sahen die schon noch relativ stabil aus. Aber das war halt trotzdem ein Diktator und dass der irgendwann kippt, das hätte man eigentlich auch sehen können.
Die Diskussion um Huberachs Nachfolge lief ja schon eine Weile seit 2006 etwa.
Der ist ja auch, wie alt ist der? 80?
Über 80. Und da lohnt es auch, die Wikileaks-Cables zu dem Thema zu lesen.
Das hat sich Wikileaks erfreulicherweise nicht nehmen lassen. Jetzt passend zur Krise haben sie einmal nach Ägypten gegreppt in ihrer Datenbank und haben die ganzen Depesche zu Ägypten rausgehauen. Und da sind einige richtig saftige dabei. Die Lektüre ist im Vorn.
Ja, also wir haben gerade Bestätigung, Noah ist tatsächlich down. Also die haben sie offensichtlich auch komplett abgeschaltet.
Na prima.
Also damit ist denn...
Der Kompromatkoffer war leerer, als sie dachten.
Ist ja keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht musste noch eine Familie mit Mitglied seine Online-Fotosammlung back-upen, bevor sie Noah-Oterfahrt konnten. Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, die interessante Frage ist jetzt natürlich, was irgendwie nun auf der Fernseh-Ebene passieren wird. Aber gut. Ja.
Sehen wir dann.
Sehen wir dann, ne?
Ja, wir haben uns überlegt, wir sollten vielleicht mal ein kleines Hörspiel machen.
Ein kleines Hörspiel, ja, richtig, genau. Die Frage war ja, wie stellt man sich das mal so vor?
Wie ist denn eigentlich eine Revolution?
Wie funktioniert denn so eine Revolution?
Und wir haben zwar auch noch keine Revolution gemacht, aber wir haben darüber nachgedacht.
Und wir haben jetzt mal ein kleines Land in irgendwo auf der Welt, der mit dem schönen Namen Absurdistan, und in diesem Land ist El Fefe der Diktator.
Der Chef.
Ein fiesen Revolution namens Frank Gewahrer.
Ja, und Fefe ist seit 20 Jahren einer Macht, und das muss sich langsam mal ändern, weil er ist auch wirklich ein etwas übler Diktator, weil er ist einer von intelligenteren.
Ein fieser, fieser Diktator. Und wir haben uns gedacht, wir versuchen mal zu beleuchten, so die Phasen in einer Revolution, und was eigentlich die Ziele und Prioritäten sind, an jeder Stelle, und was man so machen würde.
Genau.
Wir haben es nicht ganz bis zu ende durch. Wir werden also am ende vielleicht ein bisschen improvisieren müssen.
Ja. Gut, also die erste Phase natürlich, wir müssen erst konspirativ reden und planen können. Also wir müssen halt irgendwie in der Lage sein, uns zumindest mal abzustimmen und festzustellen, was irgendwie an der Elfefe denn nun irgendwie so doof ist. Und wir müssen als Revolutioner natürlich in der Lage sein, zumindest mal Alternativen zu entwickeln, also zu sagen, wie soll es denn nach der Revolution aussehen. Und hat natürlich irgendwie einen...
Da tue ich natürlich nichts gegen. Denn wenn ich die jetzt zensiere, dann gebe ich ihnen ja erst den Grund in die Hand, warum sie was gegen mich tun sollen. Denn solange es so eine Pseudo-Freieheit gibt, findet sich keine kritische Masse, um eine Revolution zu machen. Solange die Leute die Illusion haben, dass sie frei sind, tut sich auch nichts. Erst wenn du das Internet abdrehst, dann merken die, dass sie unfrei sind. oder wenn es wirklich offensichtlich und nicht mehr zu leugnen ist, denn die meisten Leute wollen ja glauben, dass sie eigentlich in einer Demokratie leben. Das heißt, eigentlich lasse ich die Revolution... Die sollen mal ruhig miteinander reden und mein Geheimdienst guckt dann, was er rausfinden kann über Traffic-Analyse und Inhalte abschnorcheln.
Genau, das ist halt der Nachteil daran, dass wenn alle noch das Gefühl haben, sie könnten ja eigentlich frei reden, als es nur so am rande halt irgendwie so ein Unwohlsein gibt, also so dieses inhärente Gefühl des Überwachs seins so, dann kommunizieren die mutigeren Leute halt eben trotzdem so. Und dann sieht Fefes Geheimpolizei das leider beim reden so.
Ich hab meine Akten.
Du hast deine Akten. Ja, die nächste Sache ist natürlich die Sache mit dem die Deutungswort über die Medien.
Ja, also die man es gibt ja häufig so die idee, ein Diktator, was er als wichtigstes hat, ist, dass er die Zensur einführt und durchhält. Aber eigentlich will man gar nicht direkt zensieren. Das ist sogar kontraproduktiv, weil es nämlich offenbart, dass du ein Problem hast als Diktator. Denn viel bessere Diktatur ist, wenn der Diktator gar nichts manipulieren muss, weil die Medien von sich aus nur das schreiben, was ich will. Also eigentlich möchte ich so eine Pseudo-Freie Presse haben als Diktator, die am ende alle dasselbe berichten und am besten irgendwelche Sachen, die völlig uninteressant sind. Also nichts Politik, sondern Sport und so. Und das kann ich herbeiführen, indem ich die Verlagshäuser fusioniere, indem es dann ein wirtschaftliches Umfeld gibt, indem die Verlage alle kaum noch Kohle machen und sich keiner mehr richtigen Journalismus leisten kann. Und dann gibt es am ende die Burda, Bertelsmann, Springer, GmbH, die 25 Zeitungen rausbringt. Und die sehen alle für den unaufmerksamen Bürger aus, als wenn sie wie eigentlich andere Zeitungen sind und miteinander konkurrieren. Aber im grunde ist alle dieselbe Mischproke. Das ist, was ich hier beiführen will.
Naja, die Gegenstrategie der Revolution ist natürlich, dass wir nach ein paar Journalisten suchen, die halt irgendwie noch Mut haben und halt versuchen, da über diese ein paar Mediascoupes zu landen, um El-Fefe den Diktator zu diskreditieren. Und wenn wir die nicht finden, so was ja durchaus sein kann, weil irgendwie El-Fefe ist ja ganz gut in der Medienmanipulation, dann müssen wir halt ins Ausland gehen. Also dann müssen wir halt uns irgendwie gucken, was so ein Satellitensinn an bei uns ist. Wir müssen gucken, was im Internet geht. Dann könnten wir uns zur Not uns halt irgendwie an die Amis wenden, die halt radiofreie Absurdistan betreiben, um halt irgendwie in unser Land einzustrahlen.
Na, das kann ich mir natürlich nicht bieten lassen, aber wenn ich direkt dagegen vorgehe, dann offenbart das wieder Schwäche und dass ich dann Probleme sehe. Deswegen ist das PR technisch nicht schlau. Was ich deswegen eigentlich tue, ist, dass ich das Umfeld der Leute diskreditiere. Also bei Demonstrationen schmugle ich Provokateure ein, die dann sich Schlachten mit der Polizei liefern. Und sofort ist die Medienberichterstattung völlig klar. Nämlich hier sind irgendwelche fiesen Hooligans am Werk. oder wenn es um Inhalte geht bei den Stories und gar nicht so die Leute diskreditierbar sind, dann kann ich dann dafür sorgen, dass unglaubwürdige Leute ähnlicher Theorien interviewt werden. Also zum Beispiel irgendwelche Ufologen. oder bei 9-Eleven hat man das gesehen. Das funktioniert ganz hervorragend, wenn man da irgendwelche Spinner dann ihren Müll einbringen lässt. Und schon ist das ganze Movement diskreditiert. Also da muss ich mir nicht viel Sorgen machen.
Na gut, sowas machen wir natürlich auch. Also diese sozusagen sleazy Stories über Fefe und seinen großen Clan kriegen wir auch hin. Also man darf ja nicht vergessen, Macht korrumpiert sind. Alle Diktatoren haben irgendwelche schlechten Gewohnheiten. So fressen kleine Katzen oder vergewaltigen Frosche oder sowas. Und das kann man natürlich für Gerüchte benutzen. Also das ist halt allgemein bekannt auf der Gerüchteebene, was irgendwie für einen dieser Kerle Fefe ist. Und das ist halt sein Clan, wie es in all diesen Diktatoren ist. Es hat da so gewisse kleptokratische Züge. Das heißt also, dem gehört halt die halbe Wirtschaft, weil sonst lohnt es sich eine Diktatur natürlich nicht. Und darauf kann man natürlich eine runde rumhacken. Und dann gibt halt der gesamte Diktator-Clan natürlich ein Ziel ab, weil jeder, der an dieser Diktatur verdient, das ist halt unser erstes Propagandaziel. Also jeden, der an dieser Diktatur davon profitiert, den halt irgendwie als schlechten Menschen dastehen zu lassen.
Na also ich wehe mich natürlich gegen kleptokratisch, weil wenn mir das gehört, ist es ja nicht gestohlen. Mir gehört die Wirtschaft. Und was ich dagegen tue, meinen ganzen Clan angreifbar zu machen, ist, dass ich die einfach alle involviere, dann haben die alle persönlich was zu verlieren. Der Chef des Geheimdienstes, die Polizei, Armee, Luftwaffe, Marine, alles irgendwelche Söhne, Cousins, Schwager, Enkel, Verwandte jedenfalls. Und die haben dann die Motivation, erstens sich nicht erwischen zu lassen und zweitens, wenn sie erwischt wurden, da auch nachdrücklich gegen vorzugehen.
Ja na klar, das können sie natürlich probieren, aber das Ausmaß ist natürlich groß. Macht korrumpiert natürlich, da gibt es genug Material. Und wir haben dann halt eine geheime Kampagne angefangen, genau die Bediensteten, also die irgendwie Kammerdiener und irgendwie Kellner und sonstigen Leute, die da halt irgendwie bei diesen korrumpierenden Clans für wenig Geld halt bezahlt werden, denen halt kleine Kameras zu geben und dafür zu sorgen, dass es halt genügend juicy stories gibt und heimliche bilder und also einfach dafür zu sorgen, dass wir genügend aufmonitioniert sind für den Tag, wo wir diese Sachen verwenden können, um eben auch die zweite und dritte Reihe von El Fefe's Diktatur zu diskreditieren, wenn wir es dann halt mal brauchen. Weil es kann ja nicht sein, dass es jetzt so ist, wie da in Ägypten, dass wir uns halt nur auf El Fefe den Diktator einschießen, sondern wir wollen ja den Wind gleich dann seinen ganzen Kran absolviert haben.
Ja, das ist natürlich eigentlich taktisch unklug, was sie da machen. Denn wenn sie mir alle Leute wegdiskreditieren, dann geht es ja nach der Revolution auch nicht weiter. Also das ist kein Weg. Aber grundsätzlich, die Leute, wenn die gar nicht konspirieren können, das ist zwar gut, aber besser ist, wenn sie nicht konspirieren wollen. Der normale Weg, den Diktatoren gehen, ist, dass sie daneben Überwachung machen oder Angst vor Überwachung benutzen. Aber der viel bessere Weg ist, den wir in unseren Demokratien im Westen benutzen, ist, dass wir die Leute ablenken. Wir haben so einen fußball-bundesliga. Wir haben Titten auf der Bildtitelseite. Wir haben entführte Mädchen-Geschichten. Wir haben modetrends. Wir berichten weiträumig über irgendwelche Wetterphänomene. Winter, die angeblich immer schlimmer werden. Wir haben genug Scheiße in den Medien, um die Leute abzulenken. Und da interessiert sich keine Sau für meine Familie.
Wir sehen also, Fefe hat von westlicher Medientaktik geladen für seine LFV-Diktatur. Aber diese Kleptografie, Kleptokratie, die da... Kleptografie. Gibt es tatsächlich. Das ist übrigens der Zweck der Kleptografie, der Kies klaut. Seine Kleptografie ist ganz schön übel. Und eigentlich ist allen klar, dass es schon ziemlich scheiße ist. Es ist sozusagen dieses offene Geheimnis, wo keiner drüber reden kann. Es gibt jede Zeit diese Geheimnisse, über die niemand reden kann, aber die alle wissen. Und wie schlimm ist es mit der Korruption und der FPV-Diktatur, das wissen wir jetzt eigentlich auch schon.
Daher ist es für mich nicht nur wichtig, die Ablenkung zu schaffen für die Gefühlsausbrüche. Das ist ja kein Zufall, das Hooligans zu Gewalten neigen, denn irgendwo muss der Ärger ja raus. Und wir haben ihn ja alle anderen Möglichkeiten genommen. sondern es geht auch darum, den Leuten ganz klar zu machen, dass Dissens fruchtlos ist. Das bringt gar nichts, da irgendwie was tun zu wollen. Denn alle Leute sollen das Gefühl haben, dass sie die Einzigen sind, die gerne was tun würden. Deswegen benutzen wir das Fernsehen. Wir haben den Leuten abends eine Tagesschau, die wir ihnen ins Wohnzimmer beamen. Und da erklären wir den Leuten, was passiert ist. Und alternative Sehensmöglichkeiten werden gar nicht erst angesprochen. Und dadurch werden Leute, die das anders sehen, eben zu der Auffassung verleitet, dass sie auch die Einzigen sind, die das anders sehen. Und der herdentrieb ist ein sehr mächtiger Trieb. Das heißt, die Leute werden halt ihren Kram intern beerdigen und werden halt weiter mitlaufen. Denn das ist, was Leute eben gerne tun. Abgesehen davon werde ich natürlich auch andere Maßnahmen einleiten, um den Konsum zu fördern, damit jeder eine Spielekonsole und einen fetten Fernseher hat und damit die sich auch gar nicht irgendwie so sozial treffen, sondern alle zu Hause rumhängen. Und das ist natürlich doof, wenn die dann World of Warcraft spielen und da möglicherweise das die Chat-Funktion benutzen, aber naja.
Du meinst zumindest, sind sie nicht auf der Straße.
Ist besser, als wenn sie auf der Straße sind.
Ja, als Revoluzzer braucht es natürlich eine Art Durchbruch-Event, also einen Zeitpunkt, der es möglich macht, bzw. allgemein üblich macht, darüber zu reden, wie scheiße dann Elphi fürs Diktatur ist. Und wir können den möglicherweise nicht arrangieren, also müssen wir möglicherweise drauf warten, so wie es denn so in Tunesien war. Aber naja, ist das halt so, dass die Perspektive der Leute auf der Straße, die wir überzeugen wollen an unserer schönen, kleinen Revolution, mitzumachen, da geht es darum, dass sie erkennen, dass es ihnen nicht alleine so geht, dass sie es scheiße finden. sondern genau so ein Event wollen wir erzeugen. Und unser Ziel dabei ist natürlich, wir wollen den Diktator natürlich dazu bringen, Zensur einzuführen, um eben auch die sünden seines Clans zu kaschieren. Und da haben wir dafür gesorgt mittlerweile, dass die Berichterstattung nicht aus dem Ausland darüber, wie scheiße LV ist, mittlerweile so ein bisschen größere Züge angenommen hat. Und wir haben es jetzt geschafft. Irgendwie der Diktator muss Zensur einführen. Also zumindest für einige Webseiten und Zeitungen, weil es einfach zu viele Storys und Berichte aus dem Ausland sind, die ihn diskreditieren.
Ja, der Weg dahin ist natürlich scheiße. Was ich natürlich als erstes tue, ist, dass ich die Deutungshoheit ausnutze, die ich habe, indem ich gucke, dass die tv-sender, wenn sie über das Ausland berichten, klarmachen, dass es delegitimiert wird, was die da tun. Das ist ein echtes Problem, wenn man sieht, dass das Nachbarland gerade Revolution macht, weil die mit ihrer Regierung unzufrieden sind, dann muss auch meine Regierung gucken, dass die Leute nicht darauf die idee kommen, dass es hier auch ging. Aber gut, wenn es soweit ist, dass ich es dann so einführen muss, dann muss ich natürlich erstmal dafür sorgen, dass den Leuten klar ist, dass es persönliche Konsequenzen für sie hat, wenn sie irgendwas tun. Deswegen suche ich mir als erstes ein paar ganz fiese Gerüchteköche aus, die Vorschreier am besten ist, wenn man nur einen hat. Deswegen gibt es auch bei Al-Kaida eigentlich nur den Bin laden und gelegentlich haben sie eine rechte Hand, die sie erwischen oder erwischt haben. Das hat ja auch schon wieder sein ende gefunden. Aber da geht es immer darum, dass du jemanden hast, auf dem du zeigen kannst und den kannst du dann öffentlich hinrichten oder was weiß ich, was du mit dem tust. Ich würde als Diktator tatsächlich ein Gerichtsverfahren machen mit meiner korrupten Justiz und würde auch durchaus zulassen, dass es durch die Instanzen geht. Denn während das durch die Instanzen geht, ist der Typ in der Defensive und hat keine freude am Leben, sitzt vielleicht gar in Untersuchungshaft und am ende wird er verurteilt und landet lebenslang irgendwo oder von mir aus, was weiß ich. Vielleicht gibt es auch todesstrafe in meinem Land, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber mir würde es darum gehen, auf der einen Seite darzustellen, guckt mal, hier gibt es eine Justiz, auf die man sich verlassen kann, aber die ist auch auf meiner Seite. Das wäre die Botschaft daran. Dann ein Exempel statuieren und dem Einzelnen sollte an der Stelle dann klar sein, wenn ich hier den Mund aufmache in dem Regime, dann riskiere ich meine Karriere, meine Familie, mein Leben und darauf hin halten alle die Klappe, ist die Hoffnung. Ich achte natürlich auch darauf, dass meine eigenen Medien alle dieselbe Linie fahren. wieder damit die einzelnen Leute glauben, sie seien die Einzigen, die anders denken. Und andere Medien als die meinigen, denen sage ich natürlich relativ klar, dass ihre Lizenz jederzeit kündbar ist.
Ich verstehe. Na gut, aber damit ist natürlich der interessante Punkt überschritten, wo nämlich es verbotene Geschichten gibt. Also wo allen klar ist, dass bestimmte Geschichten verboten sind. Die wären dadurch natürlich viel interessanter. Dann fangen wir halt an, als Revoluzzer diese Stories auf Social-Media-Seiten und viral via Mobiltelefone zu verbreiten. Also wir wollen unsere Stories da platzieren, wo es am meisten Aufmerksamkeit erregt, wenn Fefe diese Seiten zensieren muss. Also zum Beispiel Facebook oder Twitter oder ähnliche Dinge. Und wir machen natürlich auch so ganz konventionelle Sachen, wie zum Beispiel so kurze Propagandamovies hinten auf die video-kassetten von Lime-Movies mit drauf spielen auf die letzten drei Minuten, die da noch sind. oder Pirateneinspielungen an kabelsender, so auf der Straße kurz die Kabelbox knacken und dann einen kleinen kabelsender reintun, mit dem wir halt in der Lage sind, unsere Propaganda da reinzuspielen in die Kabelnetze. Und eben weil es interessant ist, das zu tun, gewinnen wir da halt auch immer mehr Jugendliche dazu. Und dadurch schaffen wir es so langsam, dass auch die ausländischen Medien immer mehr Aufmerksamkeit dem Problem in absurdes Tant zufinden. Das ist zwar noch nicht so richtig Top-Thema, aber wir kommen langsam dahin.
Ja, an der Stelle werden die ersten ungeschickten Kollegen von mir vielleicht nervös. Also Berlusconi hat sich neulich so ein Ding geleistet. Er hat dann bei einer Talkshow angerufen, bei dem letzten freien fernsehsender in Italien. Dann hat er die die moderatoren und Gäste angepöbelt. Aber ich würde natürlich geschickt sein.
Fefe würde sowas nie machen.
Ich das völlig unter meiner würde, sowas würde ich nicht tun. Ich würde auf diplomatischem Wege protestieren bei den anderen ländern. Ich würde denen sagen, wenn die ihre Presse nicht im Griff haben, dann können sie ihr Öl ja demnächst woanders kaufen. Und damit ist die Sache normalerweise vom Tisch.
Verstehe, ja. Okay, naja gut. Also was wir tun ist, Fefe hat natürlich auch eine fiese Geheimpolizei, worüber er nicht so gerne redet. Und wir sorgen halt dafür, dass irgendwie die ausländischen Journalisten...
Na so geheim ist die nun auch nicht.
Na ja gut, aber es ist schon klar, dass es eine, also sie heißt offiziell Geheimpolizei, damit sie einschüchternder ist. Und die hat natürlich Opfer. Also es gibt da halt irgendwie Verschleppte und Folteropfer und ermordete Regime-Kritiker und so. Und wir arrangieren dann halt irgendwie Interviews mit internationalen Medien mit eben genau diesen Opfern oder den Witwen oder ja von diesen Opfern. Und wir sorgen halt dafür, dass die Beschreibungen eher wirklich kein Auge trocken lassen und sehr grafisch sind. Und das fängt halt langsam an, dass dann die Botschafter kleinerer länder an Fragen zu stellen. So und Absurdistan wird halt irgendwie Menschenrechtsreporter UN-kritisch erwähnt. Das US-Außenministerium runzelt gelegentlich nach Augenbrauen, weil sie doch eigentlich klar gesagt haben, dass da bitte nichts von da draußen dringen soll. insbesondere von Fefe's heimlichen Retention-Knästen, die er an die Amis vermietet hat. Also geht schon langsam so in die Richtung.
Na so eine Scheiße. Das habe ich mir natürlich vorher überlegt und habe mein Personal völlig klar mitgeteilt. Die sollen keine Zeugen hinterlassen. Na so ein Scheiß. Na es gibt aber auch kein gutes Personal mehr. Ja, also auf den Unumenschenrechtsgeport da scheiß ich doch drauf. Das ist irgendwie ein Stück Papier. Das interessiert keine Sau. Das ignoriert Israel auch seit vielen Jahren erfolgreich. Da zeige ich mal kurz auf Palästina und dann habe ich die Lacher auf meiner Seite. Und wenn die Amis kommen, dann zeige ich kurz auf Guantanamo, wie mein Freund Putin neulich und dann lache ich einmal laut und dann ist das auch weg.
Wir fangen natürlich auch an, innerhalb des Regimes ein wenig zu wühlen und da gärts nun langsam. So, der Fefe ist ja nun schon seit 20 Jahren an der Macht und hat sich aber natürlich nicht nur freunde gemacht. So hat er doch gelegentlich mal Leute bei der beförderung übergangen oder dem einen oder anderen Generalen irgendwie eine zu kleine Villa geschenkt oder dergleichen Dinge mehr. Und vor allen Dingen gibt es auch so einige jüngere Offiziere, die eben durchaus an die Gurgel wollen, weil die haben durchaus irgendwie auch mal, wollen eigentlich auch mal ein bisschen mehr von der Macht abhaben und sehen nicht so richtig ein, dass dieses Regime halt so statisch ist und dass die ganzen Generäle alle an der Macht sind, bis sie 85 sind oder tot am Schreibtisch umfallen. Und mit diesen Leuten führen wir mal dann so langsam unverbindliche Gespräche beim abendessen. Und dann haben wir auch noch so gute Kontakte zu den Stiftungen von George Soros, der aufmerksam geworden ist und so ein bisschen Aktivistentrainings für die nächste runde sponsert. Also so langsam sammeln wir halt irgendwie da so so eine kleine kritische Masse zusammen.
Da ist ein undankbares Pack, diese ganzen Pöstchenbesitzer. Aber ich habe ja noch genügend andere Leute. Meine Familie ist groß und umfangreich. Und ich erinnere sie kurz daran, wem sie ihren Posten zu verdanken haben. Und dann weise ich darauf hin, dass ich noch einen Punkt mehr Cousins und Enkel habe, mit denen ich alternativ die Posten besetzen könnte. Und dann soll niemand auf Linie kommen.
Tja, dann suchen wir uns jetzt ein Thema, wo eigentlich niemand so richtig dagegen sein kann, aber das Elfefe voll verkackt hat. Und zwar den Umweltschutz. Weil die Luft in den Städten ist echt zum schneiden. Es gibt kein saure Wasser. Und die multinationalen Konzerne, die Fefe bestochen haben, damit sie da ihre Dreckfabriken hinstellen können, die sind sowieso keine Sympathisanten und empfindlich gegen Druck aus dem Ausland. Jetzt fangen wir halt parallel dazu an, an diesem Thema rumzureiten neben den Menschenrechten, wo eigentlich wir jede Menge Sympathisanten haben.
Da muss ich natürlich langsam anfangen, persönlich zu werden. Ich greife mir einen raus von den Revolutzern, fange an, gezielt gegen den PR zu fahren. Ich besitze ja die Medien, insofern kann ich da senden, was ich will. Da sage ich dann, das ist unser Feind, der wird uns alle kaputt machen. Dann sage ich, Arbeitsplätze sind bedroht, die Wirtschaft geht kaputt. Denkt nur an eure Rente. Die ist nämlich bei uns staatlich garantiert. Gut, die Leute werden nicht so alt wegen dem Umweltproblem, aber das ist ja nicht meine Schuld.
So oft ich viel rennte, ist es auch nicht meine Schuld.
Aber das muss sie ja nicht erwähnen bei solchen Gelegenheiten. Das ist ja nur ein Detail. Dann sage ich, guckt nur in die nachbarländer, da geht es den Leuten noch schlechter. insbesondere die Beamten sollen sich mal klar machen, dass wenn es hier ein Regimewechsel gibt, dann haben die nie wieder eine Chance. insbesondere betrifft das natürlich die Mitarbeiter von meinem umfangreichen Sicherheitsapparat.
Ja, wir haben einen...
Ach ja, im Moment, der Umweltschutz war noch gesagt. Umweltschutz, Umweltschutz, völlig überbewertet. Na gut, ich lasse sie in der Oppositionspartei gründen. Sagen wir, die Grünen, aus dem wird ihr nie was. Spätestens, wenn die mal wirklich mitregieren dürfen, dann werden die ihre ideale voll und ganz verraten und dann sind die wieder weg vom Fenster.
Ja gut, also wir fangen jetzt natürlich dann an, doch mal auch ein bisschen persönlicher zu werden, wenn Fefe persönlich wird. Wir haben jetzt über unsere Kontakte bei den Sympathisanten und den Bediensteten mittlerweile Fefes persönliche Finanzrekords gefunden und die seines Clans. Und publizieren die halt über eine im Ausland gelegene Webseite, die auch eine große Verbreitung erreicht. Und das ist dann halt das Gesprächsthema auf den Straßen und selbst die ersten Regierungskritischen Zeitungen fangen an, Fragen zu stellen, wo Fefe dann irgendwie sein vergoldetes Automobot her hat. Und wie ist denn jetzt eigentlich irgendwie um die 50 milliarden bestellt, dass die irgendwie in ein privates Mondprogramm investiert und wieso die nicht in die Bildung in unserem Land investiert werden?
Na, das ist natürlich ein harter Turbak, da muss ich hart gegenhalten. Und ich liege dieser Site dann erst mal ein paar Unterlagen über das Mondprogramm von Israel und Beweise, dass die nasa-modelandung gefälscht war und patschuße sie die Passion von irgendwo anders, jedenfalls nicht aus meinem Land. Und im Übrigen Bildung finde ich überbewertet, ja. Die Leute, das ist doch Bildung, wenn ich hier ein Mondprogramm mache. Aber was wollen die denn alle?
Ja, wir sehen, der Fefe entfernt sich so langsam so ein bisschen von der Realität. Also der gemeine Mann auf der Straße kann den Fefe ja, rahn es nicht mehr so richtig voll, so die wirken nach und nach so ein bisschen deplatziert. Ist ja schön und gut, dass er zum Mond will, aber solange die Leute halt irgendwie...
Nein, nicht ihr. Die Menschheit will zum Mond.
Na ja, aber...
Wenn die Amis schon nicht da waren.
Ja, aber wir haben dummerweise irgendwie die internen Unterlagen von diesem Mondprogramm gefunden, unter anderem halt auch die Gewichts-
Das ist natürlich schlecht.
Die Gewichts- und Dimensionsmaße des Sitzes in der Mondraketo, die passen zufällig zur Elfefe. Und da besteht nicht mehr so viel Zweifel, dass Fefe also offensichtlich derjenige ist, der mit den Schätzen unseres landes ein privates Mondprogramm finanzieren will. Und langsam gärt dann die Unruhe in der Bevölkerung halt immer stärker. Und es gibt dann schon so die ersten Fragen auch aus dem Elfefe-Klan, ob sie dann nicht eigentlich mit dem Geld auch noch was besseres hätten machen können, wenn man zum Beispiel Yachten kauft oder sowas in der größten Klasse.
Ja, na ich denke es ist dann langsam an der Zeit, dass ich mal mein Mondprogramm ausprobiere, 150 Tonnen Gold einlade und mich als Exil nach England begebe zu den guten alten freunden aus der Kolonialzeit.
Wie so schnell? Wir haben auch gar nicht angefangen zu demonstrieren.
Habt ihr noch gar nicht. Ihr habt auch wie gelegs gelebt. Du weißt, ich soll noch raus, soll noch raushalten.
Ja, du musst noch raus. Ich halt noch raus. Aber du hast dein Gold schon mal beiseite. Mein Gold hab ich schon mal beiseite. Das hätte ich auch getan. Gut, also wir fangen jetzt an zu demonstrieren. Also fangen wir mit einer kleinen Demonstration an, wie üblich mit den studenten, die irgendwie am radikalsten sind und am wenigsten zu verlieren haben und am schnellsten rennen können. Und die Demonstration findet statt vor dem Bildungsministerium und wir fordern bessere Studienbedingungen, mehr Stipendien für alle und Professoren, die nicht irgendwie in der fpf-ideologie indoktriniert sind, sondern tatsächlich was auf dem Kasten haben.
Na gut, diese Art von Demonstrationen kennt man eigentlich aus allen westlichen ländern. Das kann ich glaube ich aussitzen.
Sitz sie einfach aus.
Muss ich nichts machen. bildungsdemonstration. studenten, die mit Unis unzufrieden sind, aber das lockt doch keine Davos.
Die nächste Demonstration geht zu LFE fürs privatem Jachthafen.
Langsam wird mir das aber unangenehm hier.
Jetzt ziehen wir also zu LFE fürs privatem Jachthafen, weil was wir provozieren wollen, ist eine Konfrontation on camera, die irgendwie in alle Welt gestreamt wird, um sicherzustellen, wie die entsprechenden bilder im Fernsehen haben überall.
Na die Blödsinn gebe ich mir natürlich nicht, aber meiner Jacht aufzutrauchen. Ich sage stattdessen, ich bin entsetzt über die Ausschweifung meines Politbüros und bin schockiert, dass solche Nattern in meiner Nähe sich aufhalten konnten und konfiziere die Jachten und versteigere sie für den guten Zweck im Ausland.
Wir haben uns jetzt mit dem Bauernverband zusammengeschlossen und haben eine Demonstration organisiert von 500 Treckern und Mähdreschern in der Innenstadt, die für bessere getreidesubventionen und mehr Kühe demonstrieren.
Oh, das ist perfekt, das kann ich gut nutzen. Dann sage ich das zu, sage es gibt jetzt billigeres Essen für die Bevölkerung, das funktioniert immer gut in Krisensituationen. Ja, dann importiere ich ein bisschen von meinen transatlantischen freunden, lasse ich mir ein bisschen Gen-Weizen-Sponsoren und verteile den unter der Bevölkerung, dann kann ich auch gleich meine freunden bei Monsanto im Kickback entlocken. Das ist perfekt, besser läuft es, besser kann es gar nicht laufen für mich. Die Bevölkerung ist wieder zufrieden, großer Schritt zurück für die Revolution.
Wir sehen schon, der Tief ist ein ungewöhnlich kompetenter Diktator. Wir hoffen, dass er niemals absurdes Teil übernimmt. Gut, wir eskalieren die Demonstration. Wir rufen auf zum Million-Man-March against El Fefe für Dienstag.
Da lache ich doch drüber. Da frage ich mal bei meinen bildungsfreunden an, wie das mit dem Wetter Manipulator geworden ist. Ob der inzwischen einsatzfähig ist.
Naja, der ist leider nicht einsatzfähig. Wir schaffen es immerhin, 500.000 Leute in der Innenstadt zusammenzukramen, trotz irgendwie Einstellung des Zugverkehrs und blockade der Autobahnen.
Dabei ist doch ein kleines blauäugiges Mädchen entführt worden im Nachbarland. Hast du es nicht gesehen? Alle fernsehsender haben davon berichtet. Ist dir das entgangen? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Naja, 500.000, was ist denn 500.000? Bei uns wohl 82 Millionen.
Nein, der absurdestein ist nicht so groß.
absurdestein ist nicht so groß? Aber man hat sich da nicht fertig.
absurdestein hat nur 14 Millionen Einwohner. Na gut.
Ja, da lache ich trotzdem drüber. Das Fernsehen berichtet darüber, aber behauptet, es sei eine Revolution gegen den Vorgänger. Die Vorgängerregion gewesen. Zack, fotoshoppede bilder und schließt sich dem voll und ganz an. Verspricht Reformen und setzt eine Arbeitsgruppe ein, um neue Gesetze zu erarbeiten.
Die 500.000 Leute campen jetzt in der Innenstadt und überrennen deine Sicherheitskräfte auf dem Weg zum präsidenten-präsidenten.
So inkompetente Sicherheitskräfte habe ich aber nicht, dass sie sich von den paar Medikamenten...
500.000 Leute...
Ja, aber überrennen, hör mal, ich habe da Militär mit Bewaffnung und Granaten und Israelisch ausgebildet und alles, das ganze Knick.
Ja, aber dein Militär ist dir nicht mehr so ganz loyal, weil du vergisst die jungen Offiziere, die wir da irgendwie rekrutiert haben.
Ich habe doch aber Gold.
Du hast doch schon einen Ausleit geschafft.
Na Moment, ich habe doch den Kickback von Monsanto, kann ich doch benutzen.
Um den Bonus zu zahlen.
Um den Militären Bonus zu zahlen für die Loyalität.
Ja, aber das...
Und ich verspreche höhere Renten. Das Kostetnächstes kann ich immer machen.
Versprichst höhere Renten, verstehe.
Und das Essen ist immer noch so passioniert, ich meine.
Wir überrennen trotzdem mit unseren radikalen...
Ach, ihr habt doch überhaupt keine forderungen mehr, ist doch alles vom Tisch...
.Revolution überrennen bei Fefes präsidentenpalast, um die goldenen Wasserhähnen live auf Al-Jazeera zeigen zu können.
Ja, leider ist Al-Jazeeras TV-Kanal ausgefallen gerade. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie das kommen konnte. Diese Technik ist aber auch völlig unzuverlässig.
Und wir streamen die bilder von Fefes goldenen Waschbecken und hundefutterdeffen.
Jetzt ist Internet so ein Zufall. Da gab es auch technische Probleme heute. Der Zentralrouter, ach, wie kann das nur kommen? Das muss mit dem Test zusammenhängen, den die gefahren haben. Die Ankündigung ist leider verloren gegangen auf dem Weg zu den Medien.
Die Schlagzeile international lautet Al-Fefes präsidentenpalast gestürmt, Internet vollzansiert.
Ja, das sieht aber leider keiner die Schlagzeile.
Im Land nicht, aber international. Die Gerüchte sind, dass Al-Fefe auf der Flucht zu seinem Gold ist.
Ja, das ist natürlich die volle Wahrheit. Das Ticket liegt schon neben mir, ist doch klar. Aber ich gucke halt, wie lange ich noch aushalte, bevor es brenzlig wird.
Gut, also wir warten uns gerade jetzt auf die Suche mit unseren Revolutionern nach Al-Fefe.
Ich habe ja noch meine palastgarde, die besten der besten.
Das Problem sind natürlich irgendwie, dass deine Geheimpolizei gerade angefangen hat zu plündern und irgendwie für Chaos zu sorgen.
Meine Geheimpolizei plündert nicht. Alles was die plündert, sind die Archive mit dem Kompromat gegen sie. Und die sind gut gesichert, da brauchen die Wochen, bis sie durch die Türen sind. Also das geht gar nicht. Ich habe ja nur Leute, gegen die ich wirklich handfeste Sachen in der Hand habe, in meiner Privatgeheimpolizei. Da kommt ja nicht jeder rein.
Naja, aber die Taktik halt irgendwie für allgemeine öffentliche Unruhe zu sorgen, wäre jetzt schon clever. Ja, aber um dafür zu sorgen, dass die...
Soweit ist noch nicht. Wenn 500.000 auf der Straße stehen, wen will ich denn da noch...
500.000 Leute sind auf der Straße und haben dann den präsidentenpalast überrannt. Da bist du schon an dem Punkt, wo du plündern lässt, um die öffentliche Ordnung wiederherzustellen.
Das stimmt natürlich. Ich habe ja meine Provokateure völlig vergessen.
Eigentlich willst du jetzt anfangen zu plündern und irgendwie die Museen zu branchen.
Das ist richtig.
Damit du irgendwie... Das stimmt.
Das macht einen Teil meiner palastgarde.
Damit das Volk verlangt, dass es wieder öffentliche Ordnung gibt. Aber das ist halt Pech, weil wir haben daran gedacht und haben schon Nachbarschaftskomitees zum Schutz unserer Infrastruktur organisiert.
Ja, das hilft ja nicht. Ich habe ja Tunnel unter den Mitteln. Das Schöne an Museen ist ja, dass sie einen dicken Keller haben, wo man Sachen lagern kann, wie zum Beispiel meine Goldvorräte. Deswegen habe ich dafür gesorgt, dass man da im Notfall rankommt. Und ich habe die Firme ja auch vorproduziert, die ich dann zeigen kann, wo man sehen kann, dass da geplündert wird. Und da glaubt dir doch keiner, wenn du da irgendwelche Menschen mängst. Das ist auch der Punkt, der Punkt geht an mich.
Verstehe, okay. Na gut, aber mittlerweile haben wir es geschafft, die falschen Jäger aus der Armee heraus zu lösen und auf Jagd nach dir zu schicken.
Ich kämpfe ja, aber auch irgendwie mit der verschärften Bindung. Ich rufe einen Notstand aus. Ich behaupte, es ist ein ausländischer Terroranschlag, hat Gift in unseren Grundwasservorrat gemixt und rufe die Leute dazu auf, dass sie kein Trinkwasser aus der Leitung nehmen. Und stattdessen wird meine Armee anfangen, Wasser zu verteilen. Und die Polizei natürlich. Und dann werden die Leute mir wieder glauben, dass die Polizei und die Armee eigentlich auf ihrer Seite sind.
Wir schmuggeln LSD in das Trinkwasser, das du verteilst.
Na, das ist auch in Ordnung. Dann sehen die Leute alle, werden glücklich und zufrieden.
Nee, nicht auf LSD. Na gut, okay, streichen wir den letzten Wuf, der es so dreht. Okay, ja gut, okay, langsam haben wir schon ein Problem. Also ist halt so eine, die Revolution zieht sich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile hin. Und Fefe ist ein echt ungewöhnlich kompetenter Diktator. Und das heißt, wir müssen uns jetzt Hilfe aus dem Ausland holen. So, also wir haben halt irgendwie die ö-kundenländer, die von...
Das sind doch aber alles meine freunde.
Die sind schon ein gewissermaßen unruhig, weil...
China kauft bei mir einen, damit ist doch die Sache vom Tisch.
Wir fangen jetzt aber an, irgendwie die ölinfrastruktur-klandestinen anzugreifen.
Na die habe ich doch natürlich besonders gesichert.
Na ja, es hilft dir aber auch nicht.
Da greift doch keine Sau an.
Na ja, also Raffinerien kannst du nicht wirklich gegen Granatwerfer beschutzt schützen.
Na du kannst natürlich einen dicken Speckgürtel drumrum abklemmen. Also da brauchst du schon eine Kurzstreckenrakete, um eine Raffinerien zu treffen.
Und die Pipelines sind auch angreifbar.
Ja, die Pipelines sind angreifbar. Aber das ist ja ein Terrorakt. Da kann ich halt sagen, guck mal Leute hier unsere...
Gut, jedenfalls radikalisch.
Dann sag ich den Leuten, guck mal eure Renten sind in Gefahr, weil Terroristen... Ich hätte euch Renten gezahlt, aber seht ihr, diese Terroristen greifen euren... unser aller... Besitztum an.
Arbeitsplätze sind gefehlt. So langsam wachsen auch in deinem Sicherheitsapparat Zweifel daran, dass du das noch hinbekommst. Weil so links und rechts irgendwie ist die Scheiße am Dampfen.
Das halt ich ja für ein Gerücht.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Meinten sich als Apparat sind die besten der besten, Sir.
Verstehe, die besten der besten. Wir haben sie trotzdem infiltriert.
Na ja, das glaub ich nicht.
Doch.
Die werden alle ausgemerzt.
Natürlich. Ich mache umfangreiche Befragungen innerhalb des Security-Apparats.
Und fürs Säuberungen durch.
Natürlich.
Die internationale Schlagzeile lautet irgendwie, Fefe hat seinen Sicherheitsapparat nicht mehr im Griff und muss Säuberungen durchführen.
Nix ist. Ich mache Gegenschlagzeilen, Terroristen gefunden haben, ausländische Mächte haben unseren Sicherheitsapparat infiltriert.
Aber deine Medien haben...
Gefahr für Bevölkerung abgewendet.
Aber deine Medien haben mittlerweile eine relativ schlechte Reputation.
Das stimmt doch gar nicht. Ich bin doch auf eurer Seite. Ich liebe euch doch alle.
Na gut. Also wir sehen, mit einem kompetenten Diktator ist es schwierig, Revolutionen zu machen. Und falls irgendjemand gerade noch ein Absurdistan abzugeben hat, wäre Fefe. Aussetzen wäre Fefe durchaus ein geeigneter Kandidat für die Diktatur. Ja, also wir können sehr gespannt sein, wie die Sache in Ägypten ausgeht. Ob sich da...
Na, ich denke mal, der Mubarak ist da nicht zu halten.
Ja, der Mubarak vielleicht nicht, aber vielleicht irgendwie wird er...
Selbst wenn er zu halten ist, macht er nicht mehr lange. Ich meine, nee, ist wahr.
Nee, aber die Frage ist halt, was dann passiert. Also ob es da eine Nachfolgediktatur gibt oder ob sie da irgendwie sowas Ähnliches für Demokratie installieren.
Das ist ja ein guter Egotest für so einen Diktator, der vorgesorgt hat für den Fall, dass er alt wird.
Naja, hat er versucht, seinen Sohn noch mal hinzumanövrieren, aber der wohl offensichtlich...
Der ist geflohen heißt das, ne?
Ja, der war sehr ungültig.
Das ist eigentlich auch ein sehr schlaues Gerücht. Wenn man sowas streut...
Also, Sire hatte diese Szene, da haben sie ihren Londoner Reporter losgeschickt zu der Adresse.
Um den Typen zu finden?
Um den Typen zu finden. Da ist der hingegangen und geklingelt. Und da hat natürlich niemand aufgemacht so. Aber sie haben halt irgendwie die bilder davon so zusammengeschnitten, dass es so aussah, als wäre er auf jeden Fall in London.
Als wäre jemand da, aber es traut sich keiner aufzumachen.
So ähnlich, ja.
Gefährlich.
Also da gibt es auf jeden Fall eine Menge Dinge, die der Mubarak sicherlich nicht so clever gemacht hat wie du. Aber zumindest im Aussitzen ist er momentan auch ganz gut.
Ja, ich mein, das ist auch die beste Strategie, die man an der Stelle machen kann als Diktator.
Ja, die Frage ist halt, ob ihn die Armee...
Wenn er nicht von alleine zurücktritt, na die Armee...
Nein, die Armee ist halt nicht so richtig auf seiner Seite so, weil die haben, also die haben mit dem Sicherheitsapparat, haben die halt schon so Probleme so. Auf der anderen Seite hat er...
Aber die sind auch nicht willens, ihn abzusetzen. Da haben sie jetzt 30 Jahre Gelegenheit gehabt.
Naja, der Punkt ist halt, die diskutieren...
Also der muss jetzt irgendwie so eine Geste machen, dass er reformwillig ist.
Naja, ist im Rahmen dieser Nachfolgediskussion zu sehen. Und seinen Sohn wollen die nicht, die Armee nicht. Die wollen halt lieber einen der ihren haben.
Naja, also wenn der schlau ist, verhandelt er jetzt ein paar Jahre mit denen, bis er halt eh abtritt.
Naja, da sind halt 100.000 Leute auf der Straße, keine Ahnung, ob sie...
Naja, der muss ja nur so tun. Weißt du, der Trick bei Versprechen ist ja, dass du Sachen versprichst, die nicht sofort beginnen.
Der Punkt ist halt, wenn da weiter 100.000 Leute auf der Straße sind, dann ist halt auch nicht mehr so viel Wirtschaft vorhanden. Und das ist halt so ein Ding, was man halt nur begrenzt länger aussetzen kann. Also der nächste Schritt wäre im Übrigen Generalstrecke gewesen.
Ja, aber die haben eh deutlich über 20 Prozent Arbeitslosigkeit. Ist das nicht so?
Das ist korrekt.
Also so richtig viel.
Naja. Na gut.
Ich denke, wir werden es sehen, das bleibt spannend.
Das bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend. Ja, wir sehen. Ich würde, glaube ich, gerne noch mal einen Alternativlust zum Thema Satellitentechnik und solche Sachen machen. Da gucken wir mal, ob wir einen kompetenten Kurve für Rämpfe finden.
Einige gute Ansprechpartner werden in Frage kommen.
Genau. Ja, ansonsten bleibt aufmerksam, guckt hin. Was auch sich sehr bewährt hat, ist, gelegentlich mal einen digitalen videocorder laufen zu lassen in solchen Krisen, damit man mal wieder zurückspulen kann und einfach nochmal nachgucken kann. Ich persönlich werde ja immer sehr nervös, wenn man so irgendwie so ein Aljazeera oder so einen anderen live-sender sieht und der dann so Loops zeigt. Also weißt du, gestern Nacht hatte ich so dieses Scheiße.
Jetzt ist wirklich übel, wenn die nicht mehr zeigen wollen.
Jetzt räumen sie sie ja ab oder so. Und was ich dann aber herausstellte, war, dass die halt einfach nur schlafen gegangen sind. So und die müssen halt auch noch mal pennen, so, gell? Aber wenn halt so live-sender eben Loops zeigen, dann ist es schon in der Vergangenheit gewesen, dass es häufiger dann gerade mal die Zeit war, wo dann halt die Opposition und die Demonstranten abgeräumt wurden. Also ja, das Internet und die live-sender da zu verfolgen, das ist in jedem Fall lohnt. Und sich immer dessen bewusst sein, dass es da, also gerade in solchen Situationen gibt es halt keine objektive Berichterstattung. Also es ist halt so, dass da immer der Nebel der Krise ist da eigentlich überall. Und man muss sich selber aus vielen Quellen zusammen stoppeln, was gerade wirklich passiert und eben auch selber Aufzeichnungen haben, um nachzusehen, was denn passiert war, wann und dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Ich finde es auch immer sehr gut und vorantreibend persönlich, wenn man die zustände im Ausland mit den zuständen bei uns vergleicht und guckt, was eigentlich die großen unterschiede sind und warum wir die Sachen in Ägypten anders sehen als die Sachen in, das weiß ich, Palästina oder Polen.
Ja, Ungarn.
Ungarn, genau.
Genau. Ja.
So weit sind wir leider nicht von entfernt, so wie wir gerne hätten.
Nee, von Ungarn auf jeden Fall nicht.
Na gut.
Dann war es das mit der Alternativlos-Folge 11 zu Ägypten und dem Thema El-Fefer als Diktator.
Und Frank gewader als Revoluzze. Und wir haben noch ein paar andere schöne Sendungen in der Queue. Das wird bestimmt auch noch spielen.
Genau. Die nächste, die wir wohl aufzeichnen werden.
Na, das sagen wir noch nicht.
Das wäre ein Verrat. Das sagen wir noch nicht. Wäre ein Verrat. Genau. Also aber die nächste Sendung, die wir aufzeichnen, wird zum ersten Mal mit zwei Gästen sein. Und da werden wir, glaube ich, auch eine Menge Spaß haben. Ja, dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr noch auf den Schlitterplatten drücken wollt, dann tut das bitte. Wir freuen uns auf jeden Fall immer drüber. Und über eure Kommentare freuen wir uns natürlich auch. Und ansonsten gibt es noch den Twitterfeed Alternativlos, wo wir zumindest zur Sendung auch immer ein paar Sachen machen. Und ansonsten bleibt schön aufmerksam. Und ja, eine schöne Zeit.